what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so in an event to stay current with the
events in Marvel Comics we're going to
begin discussing the story of original
sin and the reason for this is because
again we want to stay current we want to
maintain this element of keeping up with
the current events and Marvel comics so
that we can always know what's going on
but also going back and touching on some
previous events like the Infinity
Gauntlet and the siege Dark Reign in the
House of M so that we can understand how
some of these events unfolded we can
understand how it is that the superhero
community has been led to the place that
it is now for the most part issue number
zero of the original sin storyline
doesn't do too much for us with the
exception of giving us an understanding
of the background of the watcher of uatu
the watcher and so we're gonna skip
ahead a little bit and what we see here
is that Sam Alexander the current Nova
is traveling to the moon to the Watchers
watchtower
because Sam Alexander is faced with a
quandary of sorts the question Sam
Alexander has is that if we walk to the
watcher watches if he simply just
observes things and he chronicles these
things then the question is why why does
he do this there has to be some kind of
basis behind it there has to be some
kind of reason as for why he does this
then this of course was a question that
he had asked of Captain America and Iron
Man and Captain America had simply
replied that it was a question no one
ever thought to ask before nobody ever
really asked why The Watcher watches
they just simply accept the fact that he
does and so what we see is that Sam
Alexander arrives at the Watchers lair
and meets with The Watcher but because
the watcher doesn't really talk Sam
Alexander is a little unsure how to
conduct himself under these scenarios
but what he does is he maintains the
normal etiquette for appearing at an
individual's house and he brings The
Watcher a gift he tells the watcher that
he's not really able to buy any kind of
wine or anything which for the most part
is customary when visiting somebody but
he says that in return he is he's
brought a piece of the territory whereby
the Avengers were able to stop the
expert or the Avengers and the x-men
rather we're able to stop the Phoenix
five and so this is kind of a souvenir
it's really the best thing that Sam
Alexander knows how to do in terms of
presenting a gift to watch you The
Watcher from here we see the watcher go
back into his lair and Sam Alexander is
a little tentative he's not really sure
what this means but he assumes that what
the watcher means here is that he's
intending to invite him in and so Sam
Alexander begins to follow him the Sam
Alexander looks around and realizes that
there's really no no paraphernalia with
regards to family of mementos or any
kind of pictures of friends or anything
like that it's basically just this vast
technological hive and it seems a little
a little barren it seems a little
depersonalized in the sense that there's
really nothing here to make the watcher
up here anything more than some kind of
vague unknown individual - Sam Alexander
and so what we see is that almost
immediately when Sam Alexander begins to
travel further into the Watchers lair
that his helmet goes off now if you
recall our discussion about Richard
Rider as Nova we talked about how
Richard riders helmet will inform him
when there's some kind of danger it
would give him a warning which you would
be able to interpret and of course a
counter that danger accordingly and so
think of this as a kind of spider sense
for Nova what we see going on is that
again as Noah continues to enter or
continues to travel further into the
lair of The Watcher he sees these
various forms of The Watcher and for the
most part at this point in time we don't
really know what these are all we know
is that these are just different forms
of The Watcher perhaps it's the watcher
from different realities perhaps it's
all the possibilities or all the
possible places The Watcher could have
been but for the most part we're just
kind of left to our imagination in terms
of what these Watchers could be but what
we see Sam Alexander going through here
what we see I'm understanding is this
idea that his helmet gives him
information that his helmet is warning
him but at the same time he doesn't seem
like there's a doesn't see what there's
a reason for him to be concerned now
what we see is again as SF Alexander
continues through the lair of The
Watcher he realizes that amid his his
investigation of all these ghost
versions of The Watcher as he calls it
that he's lost the lost track of the
real watcher and so he begins to go on
this sort of hunt he begins to look
around for the watcher himself
eventually he comes across what he
thinks may be some kind of a of an
armory of sorts when he opens the door
he realizes that's exactly what it is
then what we see in this armory is a
vast collection of various weapons some
of which we've seen before and some of
which we haven't and among these weapons
is the ultimate nullifier now this is a
very big deal because again we discuss
on several occasions what the ultimate
nullifier is and the ultimate nullifier
is exactly what it sounds like it
nullifies it eradicated things from
existence and this ultimate nullifier
will become important later on when we
get into the mindless ones and we see
Nik theory and various other superheroes
responding to a crisis with the mindless
ones in in New York City what we see
here is that Sam Alexander is surprised
to see that the ultimate nullifier
simply just there he understands the
effect of the no ultimate nullifier
despite the fact that he's never
actually seen it used in person but he
knows that this is a very dangerous
thing in addition he speculates here
that The Watcher was by virtue of
chronicling various events also
collecting things he was also collecting
different artifacts collecting different
weapons and things like that and maybe
it was for safekeeping we're not really
sure what what the Watchers intention
was here but what we see is that again
Sam Alexander's helmet begins to go
crazy it begins to alert him that
something very significant is taking
place with regards to to his immediate
surroundings indicating that there is a
vast amount of danger that could be
approaching him what we also see here is
that Sam Alexander begins to travel
around he begins and to look around in
search of The Watcher and again
encounters more of these ghost versions
of The Watcher and ultimately what we
see is that Sam Alexander is able to
find the watcher he's able to locate the
actual watcher of this reality and he
simply asks them if he may join and
again the watch remains silent here the
watcher doesn't answer what we see is
that Sam Alexander is looking at the
watcher in such a way to where he
understands why it is that his helmet
has been gone awry the helmets gone awry
because of something called the
multiversal friction engine and this is
what is used to power the Watchers
Watchtower and the multiversal friction
engine as I understand it is energy that
is the the result of all the multiverses
coming into contact with one another or
bumping up against one another but more
or less it's what's left over as the
multiverses exists and so this if I
understand it correctly is what feeds
the the power source of the Watchers
Watchtower in addition we see that Sam
Alexander is looking at The Watcher and
realizes that he seems to be waiting for
something he seems to be looking for
something
and that he doesn't really know what it
is he doesn't really know what it is
that The Watcher is hunting for but then
we see that as Sam Alexander gets closer
to the watcher that various screens
begin to light up and this is when we
get the backstory of who watching the
Watchers race and what we learn here is
that who watch the watcher is a member
of one of the oldest races in the
history of the universe and that these
races at that time or this race at that
time existed to both chronicle and
possibly to interact but for the most
part they were a very proud race and so
what we see is that one of the
individuals a person named M nu I
believe is the is not necessarily the
leader of the Watchers but is one of the
more respected members of the Watchers
and what we see is that
Ecore or Ike or I'm not exactly how to
pronounce it who's the father of a wat
to is in a debate with M nu and Ecore
says that it's their job it's their goal
as a more advanced race to reach out to
other races to help those races that are
less advanced to be guided properly to
take the right steps towards the
direction of becoming a more advanced
race but also be a better contributor to
the universe as a whole we see that M nu
is avidly against this M nu says that
it's not their place to involve
themselves and the goings on of races
which are lower than them of races which
are are irrelevant to them we then see
that that lot - The Watcher speaks up
the watch of the Watchers says that
because the Watchers have such vast
strength that if they don't use it to
help other people if they don't use it
to help other races advance themselves
then all their vaunted strength is
simply just a sham so what we see is
that is that M nu is in effect over he's
out voted he's overruled by the council
and I cores I guess I horse ideology
stand that the Watchers are going to
involve themselves and helping to assist
other races and the first race that they
choose as a race called the present
Prostate proselyte khun's I guess is how
you pronounce that I'm not sure why that
name had to be chosen but what we see is
that the Watchers appear to this race
bringing them the gift of nuclear energy
and we - we see the Watchers tell
the prosecute Priscilla Coons that the
nuclear energy will give them the
opportunity to advance themselves
technologically and it'll move them
lightyears ahead of where they currently
are and so what we see is that over the
course of about a decade or so this race
is able to advance themselves they're
able to eliminate hunger and disease and
they're able to usher in a new era of
what appears to be peace and so due to
the success of this we see that the
Watchers begin to expand their reach out
further into the universe they begin to
move forward and move in the direction
of touching other races but ultimately
what we see is that the the efforts of
the Watchers bring them back to to the
prostatitis planet and when they arrive
they realize that what had happened is
that given the nuclear energy that had
been gift from the Watchers that the
process of Lincoln's had in effect
destroyed themselves they had devolved
into a state of nuclear warfare and
annihilated their entire race and so
from here we see that I Corps is a very
distraught by this he is absolutely
devastated by this and so as a result he
comes to this realization that M knew
was wise that M knew was smart and
making the decision that The Watcher
should simply just Chronicle events but
they should never interact we see that
who ought to try so plead with his
father and tell him that this is not the
case that this was simply just one
example but that other races still may
chair or still may flourish they may
still grow and expand and not succumb to
the same kind of a fate that was left to
the Priscilla khun's but we see that his
father won't hear it and that his father
has taken the stance that the Watchers
should not involve themselves and their
goings on of anybody else and so from
here we transitioned back to Sam
Alexander and what we see is that Santa
Alexander begins to maybe express some
kind of remorse for what it was that had
happened to a lot to his father he says
that that he doesn't really know what to
say here he says that he tries to start
by saying that he's sorry but it just
doesn't really seem to de comprehend it
it doesn't really seem to - I guess
maybe quell the kind of grief that who
walked to the watcher has knowing that
his race had effectively contributed to
another race completely wiping itself
out due to a gift that was given in
addition he has to watcher what it is
that he watches how much of
the observable universe is it that the
The Watcher looks at and what we see is
that who watch of The Watcher reveals to
Sam Alexander the fact that he watches
everything and when we say everything we
mean absolutely everything not just this
reality but all realities in addition
the idea here is that the watcher is
looking for something and what the
watcher is looking for is given to us by
Sam Alexander when Sam Alexander comes
to the realization that all these
various images all are from different
realities when he sees that there is an
african-american version of Captain
America which may very well be a future
version of the Falcon which indicates to
us that this may not be all reality said
it may simply just be this one reality
but then we see that as Sam Alexander 's
helmet begins to to warn him that the
constant motion the influx of energy
from the the multiversal engine would
ultimately result in his destruction we
see that he realizes there's a set of
images there are there's once one event
that seems to repeat itself every single
time and every single reality and it's
always the same it never changes and
this is the instance whereby his father
had given nuclear energy to the
prosthetic uns and they had destroyed
themselves and so we see that this is
what the watcher is looking for The
Watcher is looking for one instance
whereby this didn't happen where this
race didn't eradicate itself given the
energy of nuclear power that was given
to them by the Watchers and so this is
what the watcher looks for this is what
he's been hunting for all this time and
all this really does is give us us
understanding that The Watcher has
emotion so the watcher has feelings the
watcher despite the fact that he doesn't
voice them despite the fact that his for
the most part the facial features or his
expressions don't really change that he
is part of a race that is hungry for
something that he's hungry for a way to
prove that his father was right and to
prove that his father wasn't wrong and
saying that the Watchers should relegate
themselves to simply observing and never
interacting in addition we see Sam
Alexander begin to I guess move away
begin to tell the watcher that again he
didn't necessarily want to intrude here
that he didn't want to to play the role
of somebody who didn't need to be there
and so again he pleads with The Watcher
one last time and he asked The Watcher
if The Watcher knows where his father is
because one of the big character aspects
of Sam Alexander is the location of his
father who would simply just vanished
and again this is something that we'll
get into when we do a further
explanation on the character Nova and we
get into the role that Sam Alexander
plays but we see the Sam Alexander says
The Watcher watches everything and so if
The Watcher sees everything in this
reality then surely The Watcher knows
where his father is he recognizes that
The Watcher may not be able to tell him
that The Watcher may not be able to tell
him exactly where it is it his father
sad and so we see Sam Alexander accept
the fact that and effectively
effectively tell The Watcher if he can't
tell Sam magazine Sam Alexander woods
father is and it's okay it's not a great
big huge problem and so we see that Sam
Alexander begins to move away but then
we see the watcher tell Sam Alexander
that his father is alive and so for Sam
Alexander this is a big deal and Sam
Alexander celebrates this this fact he
celebrates this recognition that his
father is very much alive as like colic
begins to come to a close what we see
here is again this element of The
Watcher having remorse of this element
of The Watcher not being an individual
who is devoid of any kind of emotion
whatsoever when the watcher takes out
the trinket that had been given to him
by Sam Alexander the piece of ground
where the x-men of the Avengers were
able to stop the the Phoenix v and he
puts it on a pedestal as a way to to
remind him or maybe as a way to to keep
it as a memento that somebody out there
is concerned about him this brings an
end to original sin issue number zero
and again all this was designed to do is
to give us an understanding of The
Watcher to give us this idea of what the
possible impacts could be if the watcher
were killed which is something that
we'll pick up with with original sin
issue number one
so original San issue number one brings
us into the original sin storyline
proper and the way that Marvel has
organized original sin force is actually
pretty good it's actually pretty
interesting what we see is that the the
groupies or the individuals who appear
in the original sin event are grouped in
such a way where we see the most common
individuals ranked first along with
these subsets the I guess the subset
teams or the teams that will form as a
branch off of different superheroes and
the order in which they will appear in
what we see here is that Wolverine Black
Widow Captain America and Nick Fury Thor
and Iron Man are the first ones to
appear and in fact these are the ones
that we will largely pick up with as the
story begins but then we see that the
smaller groupings here black panther and
man and Emma Frost Doctor Strange and
the Punisher Bucky Barnes and Moon
Knight and Gamora are going to be teams
that are formed for particular tasks
each individual team is going to perform
a task that's been laid out in order to
understand or to discover the mystery of
this whodunit story of who it was that
had killed the watcher and so what we
see here as the story opens up as the
story progresses is that we join up with
various superheroes we join up with
Captain America with Nick Fury with
Black Widow and and Wolverine and all we
really see here for the most part is
them just having some witty banter
talking about the best steak they ever
had and and so on and so forth there's
no real purpose here except to maybe
show us what these characters do or how
they relate to one another when they're
on their off time but what we see here
is that the phone of Captain America
rings and Captain America as we see is
contacted by Thor now the fact that
we're only given one half of the
conversation isn't really it doesn't
really take away from the effect what we
see here is that apparently Thor is very
panicky on the other line Thor is is
very excited or at the very least is
speaking in such a way that it gives
Captain America pause for concern
Captain America hangs up and tells
everybody that they need to gather
together and they need a head they need
to head out they need to meet with Thor
Nick Fury and chooses to stay behind he
elects to tell everybody that he will
pay for the pay for dinner that the tab
will be on him the Captain America
responds by saying no
that this is such a significant event
that Nick Fury needs to join them Nick
Fury asked what it is that's so bad that
Captain America requires his attendants
and Captain America says that this is on
the moon this is an event that's taking
place regarding the moon and Nick Fury
says okay he finally agrees to travel
with them from here we switch to the
perspective of Wolverine and black
panther I'm sorry yeah Black Widow Thor
Iron Man Captain America and Nick Fury
and we see that someone has murdered the
watcher somebody has killed the watcher
and this is very important here and the
reason why is because as Nick Fury will
explain later on there are not very many
people that can do this
and so what we see is this may be crime
scene investigation of source where we
see various individuals trying to
understand what's gone on here trying to
figure out what's taken place but
because of the fact of The Watcher is so
enigmatic to them they don't really know
how to prove how did it proceed for
example Captain America says or ask if
they should check for a pulse but they
don't even know if he ever really had a
pulse to begin with they don't know
exactly how it is a day that he
functions the fact that he can be killed
indicates of course mortality and
indicates that for the most part the
fact that he was shot in the head and
died that he probably functions in the
same way as a normal human but again
this isn't necessarily guaranteed we
also see that Tony Stark says that he's
taking readings energy readings of The
Watcher and realizes that there are no
energy readings that The Watcher is dead
what we also see here is that Ironman
says that the question has to be asked
here who could have done this who could
have killed who could have shot the
watcher and the head was a nose was it
maybe red skull in the Cosmic Cube and
we see that black widow chimes in and
Black Widow says this was done with a
gun she says that given her expertise
her experience both investigating deaths
and being the person who's perpetrated
multiple killings that she's well aware
of what the effect is when a person's
shot with a gun and this was most
certainly a gun from here we see that
wolverine asked the question what kind
of a gun could do this what kind of a
gun could be powerful enough to kill the
watcher what we also see here is that
Nick Fury chimes in and says that the
Watchers eyes are gone now this is
extremely important here and the reason
why is because we
going to see referred to as we progress
through this comic towards the end and
especially into other comics is
something that's referred to as the
unseen something called the original sin
and we will find out what this is until
much later on but what we see is that
Nick Fury investigating further says
that both of them were carved out
postmortem most likely then he asks a
question what kind of a person would
take another person's eyes what we also
see here is that for says that this is
madness this is total insanity for
somebody to kill someone and take their
eyes and we also see that Wolverine says
that there's really no scent for him to
pick up here there's no way for him to
track the person because of the fact
that the machines that were used by the
watcher to keep the place clean we're
very good at their job and so there's no
scent left from here we switch to
Captain America and Captain America more
or less takes all the information that
we've gained at this point and throws it
in such a way that we can understand it
clearly and and quickly any simply says
that there's a killer on the loose
somebody armed with a gun that can kill
the watcher and also has all the weapons
or presumably also has all the weapons
that were in the possession of the
watcher what we also see here is Captain
America talking to Nick Fury and Captain
America tells Nick Fury that he needs to
get everybody on this that he needs to
get as many groups as he can which
includes shield and sword now sword is a
group that we haven't talked about and
in fact sword actually appeared during
Joss Whedon's run of astonishing x-men
but sword stance for a sentient world
observation and response department and
sword is a counterpart to shield where
shield exists to monitor earthbound
threats to monitor earthbound
individuals both superhero super-powered
and otherwise sword monitors
extraterrestrial worlds they monitor
other aliens to ensure that there's no
kind of I don't know I guess that's a
terrestrial threat against the against
the planet Earth and so we see that the
fact that somebody could have the kind
of technology or the kind of weapon that
will be apparel for how powerful enough
to kill the watcher is a weapon that
needs or that may very well be owned by
an extraterrestrial of some kind and so
we see that of course Captain America is
including sword to rule this concept out
but what we see here is that Nick Fury
says that the number of people who even
realize The Watcher was alive is a very
small list
and the number of people who could
successfully kill the watcher is smaller
still and so he tells Captain America
that not all the names on that list are
bad guys that not everybody that had the
power to kill the watcher is a bad guy
that in may to lead to some friends
Captain America responds by saying that
The Watcher was murdered and that all he
cares about is the truth from here we
switched to Wakanda we switched to Black
Panther and we see the Black Panther is
talking to some unnamed individual in
the shadows and black panther for the
most part just gives us this
understanding that he's will away of
what's taken place or at the very least
he understands the concept of what's
gone on that the watcher has at some
point been killed and that the attempt
is being made to find out who it was
that killed him but what we see here is
that this individual is asking the
question why is it that that this
individual that this unnamed person
isn't listening the aid of Black Panther
why is he coming to Black Panther and
asking for help this person says that
the Avengers despite the fact that they
are a formidable team are sometimes just
not cut out for everything and this is
an instance where by they're not cut out
for the task that's going to be
necessary in order for this mystery to
be unraveled we see this individual has
sent some some pictures or some files of
some kind to Black Panther and Black
Panther after looking at these asks him
what it is has been sent here this
unnamed individual responds by saying
that it's a trail it's a trail that goes
in different directions but it all leads
to the same place and when Black Panther
asked what it is he says it leads to the
unseen that it leads to the original sin
from here we see Black Panther a little
irritated here because this person's
being cryptic and of course we see that
black panther asks if the the one linked
if the common theme that all these
things all these roads lead to you is
the person that killed the watcher then
we see this individual say yes this
individual says that appears to be the
case from here we see the Black Panther
again says if this is the case if you
have all the evidence here if you have
all the answers here then send the
Avengers to capture this person and we
see this unnamed individual telling
Black Panther that these aren't answers
that these are questions that may lead
to answers
and so we see that this individual says
that he's formed several teams he's
formed various individuals who are going
to come together to try to decipher this
this chaotic mystery try to come to an
understanding of what it is that has
gone on here from here we see the first
team beginning to form where we see
Scott Lang and again Scott Lang is the
the reincarnation I guess a newer
version of ant-man
and to make a very short summary
regarding his character Scott Lang was
originally an electronics tech and a
genius-level electrician's I'm sorry a
genius-level electronics guy and there
came a point where he was down on his
luck where he had a few problems and
eventually when he was watching a crime
being perpetrated he stole the outfit of
ant-man and he had used it to to keep
this crime from happening and so as a
result we saw that Hank Pym allowed
Scott Lane to continue using his ant-man
outfit and Scott Lang took on the
moniker of ant-man and what we see here
is that ant-man is joining forces with
Emma Frost and again this is all
post-civil war this is all post Avengers
vs. x-men and so on and so Emma Frost is
still considered by many to be an
outcast she's still considered by many
to be part of the force that created the
Phoenix 5 a member of the Phoenix 5 and
so of course after the events of
Avengers vs. x-men she's been cast out
by quite a large number of people what
we see here is switching we see this
kind of a scenario I guess taking place
where Emma Frost who under normal
circumstances would never join forces
with Scott Lang is now on his team but
we don't really know what the whole
purpose of this is we don't really know
why it is that they've gotten together
but what we see is this transition to
the Punisher in Los Angeles and we see
that Frank castle is apparently
torturing some person for information
Frank castle is attempting to get
answers out of him and this person is
telling him that he knows the answer to
the question that Frank Castle is asking
he tells Frank Castle that he'll take
him to where these individuals are
buried now in terms of these individuals
who they are it's not really relevant to
this story all it is is simply us at
being I guess a scene Frank Castle and
his element and what we see is that as
Frank Castle is torturing this
individual that dr. Stephen strange
appears and Steven train estranged tells
the punisher that this individual is
telling the truth
The Punisher replies by saying that he
knows that he knows this person was
telling the truth he says the first 15
minutes or for making him talk and that
the last hour was because he deserved it
and so we see dr. strange replying by
saying that this individual has had
enough and that Frank hassel and dr.
strange need to leave they need to go on
their mission and so we see the doctor
strange teleports this individual away
from here we switch to moon night and
and Bucky Barnes and what we see is that
again the the final team here is being
formed the final team is finally coming
together and as the two progress as the
two come along there I guess travel on
their route to wherever it is that they
happen to be going we see that these
individuals finally come across their
third teammate and this third teammate
is revealed to us to be Gamora the
daughter of Thanos from here we switch
back to Nick Fury and Nick Fury is
pondering this circumstance Nick Fury is
pondering this this mystery of who could
have possibly killed the watcher what
possibly could have happened that would
have would have would have led to this
he also I guess thinks on the fact that
the individual who was successfully able
to kill the watcher was a person who was
seasoned this was not the very first
time a person's ever done this that it
was not done with the shaky hand and
this person had precision accuracy this
guy knew exactly what it was that they
were doing we see that Nick Fury says
that this person has killed before this
is not the very first time this person's
ever killed anybody and so what we see
is a Captain America joins Nick Fury and
the two of them begin talking we see
that Nick Fury says that shield is
working with sword and they're using
satellite and all different forms of
surveillance to try to figure out what
in the world happened here to try to
figure out what it is that has led to
this led to this situation what we also
see is that as some bullet fragments
have been dug out of the skull of The
Watcher and that's the bullet fragments
were where gamma-irradiated now this is
extremely important here this is a very
important clue regarding this mystery
and it's very important that you guys
pay attention to this we see that the
initial idea here is to talk to Bruce
Banner to find out what's been going on
because Bruce Banner is the foremost
authority on gamma radiation from here
we see that
Captain America's conversation with Nick
Fury is interrupted when he gets an
incoming call or he gets some resonance
of a conflict taking place in New York
involving a Fantastic Four and from here
we switched to the mindless ones and the
thing now the mindless one is a general
term the mindless one is a group of
individuals they don't really have
particular names they're simply just
referred to as the mind of the mindless
ones and the mindless ones are
interdimensional beings they exist
beyond I guess in between universes
beyond our universe or in different
realities and dimensions but they have
no real will of their own their their
mindless by their very nature and so
they exist to do the bidding of whoever
it is that is able to gain their
servitude what we see here is that as
the as the thing and and the mindless
one are fighting one another that Spider
Man comes to the aid of the thing and
Spider Man is the first one to realize
that this is one of the mindless ones he
realizes that these are extra
dimensional monsters that he's fought
them before and that the power of these
things is incredible but what we see
here is that the mindless one is
telepathic the mindless one is able to
communicate using his mind and according
to Spider Man this is something that
should not happen now again this is yet
another thing that's very important here
and I hope you picked up on the number
of things that are out of the ordinary
here the number of things that are
happening regarding different characters
or scenarios that shouldn't normally
happen that seem very very strange in
addition what we see here is that as the
mindless one is communicating with Ben
Grimm and Peter Parker that while his
speech initially started out as broken
English while he initially starts out as
being unable to form proper sentences
that his speech will become inherently
better
he also says things like why was he made
to know that he was better not knowing
that he understands what pain is now
that you know what pan knows what pain
is and that he was better not knowing
what pain was we also see that at this
point the thing begins to physically
attack the mindless one and is joined by
by Peter Parker but again what we see
here is that the mindless one is
telepathically communicating the
mindless one is that they never should
have this as they never should have gone
they never should have gone to the moon
now again we don't know exactly what
this means but we're led to believe here
that perhaps whoever was at a
The Watcher had enlisted the aid of the
mindless ones and that through some kind
of a act maybe some sort of power that
we haven't seen yet maybe some sort of
ability that hasn't been displayed to us
now this individual was able to endow
this mindless one with telepathy what we
see here is that the mindless one says
that they found things there they found
things that were changing them that were
making them different that we're making
them see and they said that sorry the
mindless one says that the man on the
moon is the one who knows the man on the
moon is the one who's aware and the man
on the moon was getting revenge on them
by making them know by making them aware
but again we don't understand what this
means for we see here is that the
mindless one is wielding the ultimate
nullifier now again if you recall our
discussion on original san issue number
zero we had talked about how the the
ultimate nullifier was in the armory of
the of the watcher and so the fact of
the mindless one is now in possession of
the ultimate nullifier indicates to us
that the the mindless one was in fact on
the moon from here we see that Ben Grimm
is trying to talk the mindless one down
he's trying to get the mindless one not
to use his not to use the ultimate
nullifier he's trying to get the
mindless one to to to disarm himself
from here what we see is the mindless
was a mindless one is saying that you
can't change what I've seen that nothing
can change what he's done we also see
that he was more content he says he was
more content being mindless being
mindless before he was more content not
having a will of his own but the fact
that he's been made aware now the fact
that he has in fact been able to been
made to see means that he's now aware of
sin and that sin is all that he can see
at this point we see that Captain
America and Nick Fury arrive on the
scene and we see that when Captain
America initially out okay the the thing
Ben Grimm says not everybody and of
course were left here to see that the
mindless one had destroyed itself at
this point we again see that Captain
America initially takes over the scene
captain a Captain America initially says
that they are going to of course leave
the ultimate nullifier what it where it
is that nobody needs to touch it and
that a D containment team needs to be
brought in order for them to animal
the circumstances analyze the
environment to see if they can perhaps
gain some evidence regarding the
mindless ones and their possible
involvement with the death of the
watcher but what we see here is that
Nick Fury takes over Nick Fury says that
this has been turned into a crime scene
and that he is officially in charge from
here
we switch to two Gamora I'm sorry to
Emma Frost Scott Lang and Black Panther
and what we see here is that they're
traveling to the to the center of the
earth they're traveling to perhaps maybe
a deeper layer and not necessarily the
core and it seems a little strange to
Scott Lang that they are following
I'm sorry traveling to the center of the
earth to perhaps find who it was that
had killed the watcher what we also see
is that the that Frank castle with the
Punisher and Doctor Strange are
travelling to her own location that
they're in fact traveling to a different
dimension they're traveling to places
beyond the main earth-616 universe or we
also see here is that Gamora and Moon
Knight and Bucky Barnes are again
continuing their own search as they've
banded together and that they are
traveling throughout various places
they're going to be traveling through
space they're going to be looking
through all these different parts of the
cosmos to try to find what's been going
on to try to find perhaps the individual
who has killed the watcher from here we
switched to the mindless ones and we see
that there are a multitude of them and
we see an individual saying that he
can't control them anymore that he can't
he can't make them bend to his will
this individual saying that they're
changing that they're evolving most
likely due to the power that has been
used but what we see here is that this
develops are that these mindless ones
are evolving because of what this
individual is in possession of and that
this individual is in possession of one
of the eyes of the watcher from here
this brings an end to two original sin
issue number one and I hope you guys
enjoyed it for the most part the
beginning of original sin was pretty
riveting it was pretty exciting and it
was a very enjoyable read
but I think that what you will find a
little disappointingly so is that as we
progress with the original sin storyline
but the story will sort of begin to take
a downward spiral that will begin to
move in a direction it's maybe not
necessarily the best but again I leave
that to you guys to decide for
yourselves so as we pick up with
original sin issue number two it's very
important that you guys pay close
attention to what's going on because
what we're going to see here is that
these stories are going to take off
they're going to move extremely fast and
so there's not going to be a whole lot
of explanation in terms of who
individuals are and so on and just
because for the most part there won't be
a whole lot of time for it we're going
to get quite a bit quite a bit of
information at a very in a very short
amount of time as we progress through
these videos so what we see going on
here is we're with Emma Frost Scott Lang
and black panther as they are near the
centre of the planet and what we see is
that they've encountered the Malloys now
the Malloys are the de facto henchmen of
mole man more or less and for the most
part they're not really relevant to this
story although I would like you to keep
them in the back of your head because
what we're going to see is that when we
get to our discussion of old man Logan
the Malloys are going to play a role and
so if you're unfamiliar with them you're
going to be a little confused as to what
the relevance is regarding their
characters in that storyline but what we
see is that Emma Frost and Black Panther
are looking at the Malloys and they're
trying to figure out what's going on in
this environment what we see is that
they've encountered a giant skeleton of
sorts and they more or less figure out
that whoever it was that had been here
whoever it was it had been depositing
bodies here is a person who didn't want
anybody to find it who thought this was
a very well hidden dumping ground in
addition we see Scott Lang is looking
for various sources of radiation Scott
Lang is looking for some kind of
indication maybe gamma or radiation or
something that could help them lay out
or find this trail that will lead to who
it was that was dumping bodies in here
what we also see is that Emma Frost is
telepathically speaking with the Malloys
telling the Malloys that she's not there
to hurt them none of them are there to
hurt them that they're simply just
conducting an investigation and they'll
be out of their hair
soon but what we see is that the Malloys
simply state or as far as I'm a fraud
scandal that the Beloit don't really
know what's going on that every few
months somebody comes down there and
some bodies are deposited but they don't
really know where the bodies are coming
from and then at this point we see a
depiction of the fact that there are a
multitude of bodies here and they all
seem to be of alien origin or some kind
of extra dimensional origin all these
bodies belong to monster some of which
are relatively recent and some of which
are skeletons and make a team they've
been there for quite some time
from here we switch to a New York City
and we follow the story of Nick Fury
Captain America and others and what we
see going on here is that Nick I'm sorry
that I Captain America Black Widow
spider-man and Wolverine are pursuing
somebody in particular they're pursuing
something although at this point we
don't really know what it is but what we
see is that this is one of the mindless
ones and again these are extra
dimensional beings that for the most
part don't really are not supposed to
really have their own will they simply
just do as they're told more or less and
what we see is that while Captain
America and in spider-man Wolverine and
Black Widow were chasing the mindless
one they're giving Nick Fury information
Nick Fury's flying around the side of
the building and they're informing him
of where it's at what we see is that the
mindless one jumps out of the building
and lands in the car in a Nick Fury's
hover car and we see that again this
mindless one is displaying telepathy
here dis- ones displaying the fact that
it does have a mind we see that it
pleads with Nick Fury to let it go that
he has to keep running and then he has
to keep running to outrun his own mind
indicating that this was just a sudden
burst of intelligence this was a sudden
introduction of entitle intelligence to
the mindless ones and they don't know
how to deal with this influx of
knowledge and in telepathy indicating
that maybe the thoughts of other
individuals are pushing their way into
their mind because again they don't know
how to control their new newfound
telepathic abilities from here we see
that Nick Fury engages the defenses of
his car to try to subdue the mindless
one but it's not working
and this is very important here the
mindless one says that being on the moon
was the first time that he ever knew
what sin was and he asks whether or not
a person deserves to
died for their original sin Nick Fury
thinks this is an admission of guilt
he thinks that the mindless one is
admitting that he had killed the watcher
and the mindless one simply replies by
saying that he still can't look I can't
bear to look at the Watchers eye at this
point we see Nick Fury jettison from the
car he initiates the ejection mode and
with his jetpack on is able to escape
and effectively crashes the car at this
point and we see the mindless 1 pleading
that he wants to be mindless again that
he wants to he doesn't want to have any
sort of intelligence that he demands to
be made ignorant again but we see that
of course this is not something Nick
Fury can grant and Nick Fury simply just
shoots the car and blows the car up from
here we transition to Doctor Strange and
the Punisher and we see that this system
we just listed as elsewhere that simply
described to us as somewhere far beyond
the realms of men but what Doctor
Strange tells us is that this is a realm
of man-eating shadows and again if you
recall our discussion on Doctor Strange
what we had talked about is that dr.
strange during his solo storylines or
even during his storylines of strange
tales would constantly visit various
dimensions some of which were extremely
strange some of which were very
interesting and relatively familiar but
this is an instance of visiting a
dimension whereby the things are very
weird and very odd we see the Punisher
saying that are asking the question if
they thought they were supposed to be
hunting a murderer and Doctor Strange
says yes Doctor Strange says that's what
we're here for and the Punisher deduces
that they're simply supposed to be bait
in addition we see Doctor Strange say
he's conjured Birds
he's conjured these sort of energy based
birds and that they will find a murderer
murder victim regardless of where it is
from here we transition to them
teleporting to the location of the
discovered murder victim and the murder
victim appears to be some kind of an
ancient king of the world as I'm sorry
king of the ancient world rather as
Doctor Strange tells us and that this
creature is quite massive it's pretty
huge in size in addition we see that the
Punisher immediately gets to work on
trying to figure out what in the world
was going on here what in the world it
was that maybe killed this this creature
caused its death and again at this point
The Punisher is not really sure why he's
along
he's really not sure why he's been
brought here if they're going to be
traveling to other dimensions whereby
dr. strange is really the only one who
has any power in these locations but
what we see is that the Punisher deduces
why it is that he's here that he's here
to more or less figure out what killed
these beings while dr. strange keeps
them protected to a degree and we see
that the Punisher is able to locate a
pretty massive gamma-irradiated bullet
now from here we transition back to
earth and we're back with the mindless
once and again the mindless ones are or
quoting different things their their
minds are catching up to the fact that
there's a lot of intelligence to be
gained and we don't really know again
how it is it this happened we don't
really know how it is that the mindless
ones were able to gain their abilities
shy of looking into the eye of the
watcher in addition we see that the two
unnamed individuals that we had yet to
see are again in possession of one of
the Watchers eyes and they're talking
about how the the mindless ones are
evolving how they are expanding in terms
of their overall abilities with its so
are these two individuals so they are
gaining more power simply just by being
in possession or maybe he's looking into
the eye of the watcher from here we see
these individuals continuing to talk
these individuals are saying things like
you know the idea of I'm sorry facing
the Avengers the idea of the fact that
the Avengers will eventually come for
them and we see this individual simply
saying that the Avengers will not be
able to handle this when they arrive
that when the Avengers show up to
confront this individual that the
Avengers are going to be faced with the
power of the Watchers I from here we see
this individual yelling out calling to
various individuals but what we see is
that this this group of individuals are
in fact the Avengers proper that for the
most part all the Avengers including
Nick Fury's team the team of of Black
Panther Scott Lang and Emma Frost and
dr. Strange's team are converging on the
honestest tower where these individuals
are housing the mindless ones in
addition to the Watchers eyes and what
we see is that the mindless ones and
exterminate ryx who is the daughter of
dr. Midas begin to attack the Avengers
now exterminators as a character that we
haven't really
talked about yet and in truth she's not
really relevant she's a one of these
instances of a character who's being
elevated but is it really a character
who matters that much but what we see
going on here is that the mindless ones
and exterminate tricks get into a very
drawn-out brawl with the Avengers we see
that Richard I'm sorry that Sam
Alexander of Nova Corps along with
various other individuals are fighting
the mindless ones and exterminate ryx
but what we also see here is that the
possessor of the Watchers eye is leading
someone who appears to be the thing down
a set of stairs but what we see is that
this is in fact dr. Midas now for those
of you guys who were unfamiliar with
doctor - dr. Midas is an individual who
has the power to turn anything to gold
once he touches it but he's also a
genius-level person now why it is a
doctor - as part of this story is
something that I have yet to figure out
I'm not really sure why he's here but
what we see is that this individual and
dr. Midas are talking about the Watchers
eye they're talking about how The
Watcher has seen everything in human
history and this individual who's in
possession of the eye believes that
everything that the watcher has seen is
still within his eye and he's simply
trying to find a way to to take it out
we also see here is dr. Midas asks this
individual how do we get the secrets out
of there how did we get the secrets that
the watcher had and this individual says
that he's been trying to figure that out
but he doesn't know the answer to that
in addition we see that once this
individual and dr. Midas get down to the
ground level we see that the mindless
ones have for the most part been totally
defeated by a combination of the thing
of the fantastic for the full new
Avenger Sam Alexander and storm of the
x-men including
daredevil and various other superheroes
and what we see is that this individual
begins to reveal himself this individual
says that the Watchers eye is a bomb and
that all bombs go boom from here we're
gonna bring him into this story and
we'll pick up with issue number three
where we learn what happens when
everyone is exposed to the to the eye of
the watcher and what happens when
everyone is exposed to the secrets that
they had long since thought dead or the
secrets they didn't think anybody else
so with original sin issue number three
what we see here is that we're picking
up almost immediately after the events
of original sin issue number two but
this issue is very very important for
the original sin storyline and the
reason why is because this storyline
will not just lay the foundation for
future actions and the storyline
involving other characters as well as
the tie-ins but it will also pertain to
the production or I guess introduction
of newer characters in the realm of
Marvel Comics as a whole and this will
become doubly so when we get to the
section of original sin where we talk
about what it was that Nick Fury had
said to Thor that caused him to lose the
ability to wield his hammer and what we
see going on here is that again this
takes place immediately after original
sin issue number two and so we're all
these members of the superhero community
the Avengers and some of the x-men had
gathered to confront dr. Midas and the
orb the orb in turn uses the powers of
the Watchers eye to expose everyone's
secrets and what we see here is that a
vast array of things are going on here
there is now new information in the
minds of various superheroes involving
other people all these secrets that
belong to anybody they had ever known
are now inside their heads and so they
know everything now with regards to the
Incredible Hulk what we will see and
hope versus Iron Man is that we'll see
this sort of storyline playing out
whereby we get a little more information
in terms of how it was that Bruce Banner
became the Incredible Hulk in the first
place and when we get into the story of
spider-man we'll learn about the these
circumstances that led to spider-man or
Peter Parker becoming spider-man and the
fact that he was not the only one that
this happened to from here what we see
going on is that dr. Midas oubliette and
in the orb or attempting to make their
getaway as a result of the fact that the
superheroes for the most part are
entirely distracted by the fact that
they're seekers have been laid bare but
what we see is that before the org can
get away he's confronted by Nick Fury
and Nick Fury tells him to put his hands
on his head and that he's under arrest
for murder what we see here with the orb
is the orb says there's no need for that
he says that he's not the one that Nick
Fury's after that the orb wants to know
who killed the watcher just as much as
Nick Fury does because it wasn't the orb
did it from here we transition back to
through black panther Emma Frost and
Scott Lang and what we see here is that
they're talking about the idea of these
bullets that they've collected through
the corpses of these bodies these
gamma-irradiated bullets and we see them
talking about how all these different
creatures all these different uh I guess
monsters or mutants or what-have-you are
here but somebody had put them here and
if somebody had the power to kill these
things and somebody must have been doing
this for a very long time and the
question has to be asked what does this
have to do how does this tie in to the
watcher being killed on the moon we see
black panther telling us that again our
killer that the killer that has
eliminated all these monsters has been
doing this for a while and has the
skills to remain hidden and so he says
that perhaps the watcher was killed
because the watcher saw this happening
the watcher saw that this individual was
killing all these things and as a result
the watcher lost his life because of it
Emma Frost goes as far as to ask the
question was it because he saw the
killer is that the most likely case and
black panther replies that the watcher
sees everything even the unseen now the
unseen is a very important element with
regards to this comic and again I'd like
you to keep this in the back of your
head because what we will see later on
as we get into or I guess as we
progressed further is that we'll learn
what the unseen is from here we
transition back to Doctor Strange and
the Punisher and the Punisher says that
this individual was shot from some
distance away that more likely most
likely it was somewhere around maybe
4,000 yards and that regardless of the
kind of gun that was used it would take
an incredibly accurate person to pull
off a shot like this frankly Frank
Castle says that this can only be done
by a handful of people on the planet
earth that maybe 10 people actually have
this skill to do this from here we see
dr. strange pondering this information
dr. strange simply say that this is a
little weird this is a little strange
and he's a little um
dissatisfied by the fact that there are
killers that are roaming these
dimensions and he doesn't really know
what the ramifications that this could
be regarding other dimensions we see a
frank acerola asking dr. strange if dr.
strange referring to him and dr. strange
says what's the difference he says
there's really no difference between
Frank hassel and whoever this anonymous
killer is where Frank Castle says that
when he kills somebody he doesn't hide
it which of course is something that I
that we're quite aware of reading
through the The Punisher comics what we
see here is that dr. strange then tells
Nick Fury I'm sorry tells how the
Punisher that if only ten people are
able to kill on this scale or able to
kill somebody from this far away with
this level of preciseness then he wants
to know who they are
he wants the exact list of those
individuals that are capable of this
kind of thing from here we switched to
Bucky Barnes Moon Knight and Gomorrha
and again these individuals are
conducting their investigation off the
planet Earth or investigating space as a
whole but at this point in the story
they haven't really encountered anything
yet where Emma Frost and Black Panther
and Scott Lang had traveled to the
center of the earth and encountered
aliens and monsters that have been
killed and Doctor Strange and Punisher
had encountered their own sort of extra
dimensional beings we see that for the
most part Gamora and Moon Knight and
Bucky Barnes haven't found anything and
because they have a phantom II thing
they feel like this is a fool's errand
Gamora says that this is silly she says
there's really no need for them to be
here that if they're going to be looking
for the murder of The Watcher there
really be no reason why the murderer
would be out in space the The Watcher
was on the moon and so most likely the
murderer is on the planet earth or hails
from the planet Earth and that they
should be investigating the earth
instead what we see here is this this
weird kind of circumstance where the the
ship that they're traveling in begins to
encounter all these bullets they begin
to effectively fly into a field of
bullets into shell casings and for the
most part they're not really sure what
in the world is going on here they don't
really understand how it is they're
flying in a bullet casings but they
continue to follow the trail from here
we see that again they're reporting
their and their information they're
reporting their investigation to an
anonymous individual who
can't see and for the most part we're
led to believe that this is the same
individual that had given their
information or given the information to
black panther that had set this entire
investigation in motion and a first
place then what we see with this
individual is that he's saying it won't
be long he's talking to we assume a
henchman of some kind and says that they
need to make things ready for when their
visitors arrive that they need to
prepare for the worst should the worst
happen in addition he says that they're
going to need a lot more of these
gamma-irradiated bullets indicating to
us that perhaps this unknown individual
is the one behind the entire conflict in
the first place from here what we see is
the orb and the orb is being
interrogated so to speak by Wolverine
and the Incredible Hulk and again this
isn't necessarily a torture session of
any kind whereby they're actually
inflicting harm but they're both using
their extreme physical prowess will rein
in his violence and The Incredible Hulk
with his sheer strength to to attempt to
threaten the orb to try to get the orb
to confess to try to get him to tell
them when the world's been going on but
what we see here is that the orb says
that while they're looking for the
person who killed the watcher while
they're looking for this individual that
he will not give them any information
that the only person he wants to talk to
is Nick Fury and that unless they bring
him Nick Fury he's not going to say
anything from here we see that again the
information this interrogation is being
seen by some some individual which of
course is uh I guess introduced to us as
Nick Fury now what it is that Nick Fury
is actually doing here what it is that
he's actually monitoring is a little
strange because what we see for the most
part is that he's keeping an eye on
everything he's monitoring everything
that has gone on here we see for the
most part that he speaks to Captain
America and Captain America says that
they've lost the trace of dr. Midas in
addition they can't find the mindless
ones apparently Ironman has lost track
of their of their scent more or less or
the ability for him to to locate him and
so for the most part they are right back
at square one what we also see here is
that as a result of the orb bringing
everybody's secrets into the light a
multitude of the superheroes about
of the superheroes have run off they've
gone to different locations we don't
really know what they're doing all we
really know is that they've disappeared
but most likely they're trying to deal
with this idea that secrets they were
previously unaware of are now common
knowledge in addition we see that Nick
Fury is examining the eye of the watch
or the eye that he had gotten from the
orb and what he says here is that this
thing seems to be a living storage
device and of course this information
came from Reed Richards that everything
The Watcher sees is quite literally
recorded within the eye itself and that
when the orb had I guess exposed
everybody's secrets that it was like
filling a series of grenades and that
everybody was previewed to everybody's
information but what we also see is that
he again continues to examine he says
the good news here is that only people
who are in the immediate vicinity were
affected me the entire world has not
been made aware of everybody else's
secrets but he says the bad news here is
that half their team is gone from here
we also see that Nick Fury asks an
interesting question he asked Captain
America what it was that he saw when he
was exposed to the secrets that he
didn't that he wasn't aware of but what
we see Captain America say is that he's
not going to tell him that it's not part
of the mission from here what we see is
that again Nick Fury kind of talking to
himself while at the same time talking
Captain America he said that it's a
little strange here that Captain America
wouldn't give him any information
wouldn't tell him what it was that he
saw because as far as Nick Fury now as
Captain America doesn't have any secrets
but Nick Fury says he has a lot of
Secrets says he has all kinds of
information and the question is why
didn't he see anything when he was
exposed to the eye of The Watcher from
here we transitioned back to Kimora Moon
Knight and Bucky Barnes and what we see
here is that they've traced the location
of these bullets to a planet and as
they're investigating this planet
they're trying to figure out what in the
world's going on there for the most part
it appears that somebody has managed to
kill an entire planet somebody has quite
literally shot bullets into the planet
itself but they can't really figure out
why they say that as far as I can tell
the radiation levels on this planet are
extremely high and so it's quite
possible that at some time or another
a civilization inhabited this planet and
the civilization itself had been wiped
out but what we see here is that there's
no signs of any kind of civilization
having been there there's no signs of
former settlements that if an individual
had arrived on the scene arrived on the
planet and annihilated the entire
civilization there would be structures
there would be something to indicate
that people had lived here in addition
we see that Bucky Barnes is able to dig
out one of the bullet fragments around
sarria a four bullet rather and he
begins to say that these are bullet
holes that the planet itself is
completely shot and riddled with bullets
and that only two circumstances are most
likely either this individual was a
terrible shot because he shot straight
down into it or he was intending to
shoot straight down into the planet in
which case the question has to be asked
why from here we see that Bucky Barnes
is able to piece together this puzzle
and he tells them to initiate a camera
to throw a camera and to orbit around
the planet and what we see here is that
as the camera begins to to shoot around
that of course Gamora and Moon I'd ask
him what what he's doing this for that
if a planet's dead they really serve
their purpose there's really nothing
else to investigate here but what we see
is that as a planet I'm sorry as the
camera begins to pan around along the
the bright side of the of the planet
that the planet itself is revealed to be
a living planet more along the lines of
something like ego the Living Planet or
something similar which of course is
very interesting here because what this
tells us is that this individual that's
been killing a multitude of aliens has
in fact killed an entire planet which
would require a vast array of both power
and prodigious skill in using various
forms of weaponry from here we
transition back on the the surface of
the planet with Bucky Barnes Gamora and
Moon Knight and what we see is of course
they're shocked to see that this
individual or this entire planet has
been eradicated that this is this entire
planet has been killed by presumably one
individual and what we see is that Bucky
Barnes is again able to piece this
together Bucky Barnes says that this
narrows down the list of people who are
capable of doing something like this
this narrows down the number of people
who are able to achieve a feat like this
and so their list of suspects becomes
much smaller than it was before what we
also see here
is that Bucky Barnes sabotages the
spaceship and leaves Gamora and moon
Knights stranded on the planet and with
no real means of escape now we will see
them return but for the most part as far
as we're concerned in this story we
don't really know what's gonna go on
with them we don't know if they're
actually gonna make it back or not from
here we see that the idea and the mind
of Gamora is that Bucky Barnes is a
prime target that Bucky Barnes is by a
virtue of sabotaging their spaceship the
I guess enemy number one he's the most
logical person to have committed this
act in the first place and that he was
simply just hiding among their ranks
from here we transition again back to
two Nick Fury and we see that Wolverine
reports to Nick Fury saying that the orb
will not divulge any of his information
to anybody except for Nick Fury and Nick
Fury says that's what he was afraid of
he says that he was afraid that the orb
would only want to talk to him
as opposed to talking to anybody else
now we don't really know why but that's
simply just the case as far as Marvel
has explained it to us what we also see
here is he's asking the question of
himself that this is an eye a single eye
that's full of secrets but the last he
checked the watcher had two eyes so the
question comes what happened to the
other one does somebody else have the
other eye at this point we see the Bucky
Barnes teleports to where Nick Fury is
currently located and Nick Fury is a
little shocked to see this Nick Fury
didn't actually expect to see Bucky
arrived but he asked Bucky word is that
he came from and Bucky immediately
without any questions whatsoever
shoots Nick Fury from here we transition
to Nick Fury on the ground unconscious
and Nick Fury of course I'm sorry not
unconscious bleeding and injured and we
see him asking Bucky why it was that he
did this why would he shoot him
Bucky says no more hiding Bucky says
that there's no more running from our
sins he says that there's no more
turning a blind eye here and he in
effect decapitates
Nick Fury and simply says no more
secrets at this point we bring an end to
original sin issue number 3 and I hope
you guys enjoyed it from here we'll
continue this investigation in terms of
the original sin storyline but we're
we're gonna be v-8 and we're gonna talk
about a couple of times we're gonna talk
about Iron Man versus Hulk and we're
going to talk about spider-man now for
those of you that recall our discussion
about Civil War this discussion on the
tie-ins is going to be very similar to
that in the sense that we're not going
to go in-depth and to everything that's
going on with spider-man at this
particular point in time if you recall
her discussion about Civil War for
example we had talked about Heroes for
Hire but all we had done when we talked
about Heroes for Hire is that the Heroes
for Hire had been contracted by Reed
Richards and the remaining members of
Reed Richards inner circle of the
Avengers to attempt to find a way to
capture Captain America and so that's
what we're gonna do here with our
discussion on spider-man we're only
going to stick with the elements of the
story that pertain to original sin now
with the way the story kicks off there's
one thing that I want to get into before
we get into the main discussion and that
is the revelation of Secrets involving
various characters in the original sins
story the way that Marvel has done this
is very ambiguous Marvel hasn't really
explained exactly how this works now
maybe it's ambiguous because it's
something they didn't account for maybe
it's something they simply forgot about
or maybe it's intentionally done that
way in order for the reader to interpret
it on their own
but the way that Marvel reveals secrets
is strange not everybody learns the
secrets of everybody else but some
individuals do and I think the way that
Marvel has done this is that individuals
only learn about secrets with things
that pertain to them directly for
example with the Incredible Hulk and
Iron Man we learn how it is that Bruce
Banner actually became the Incredible
Hulk and Bruce Banner is the one who
initiates the entire Incredible Hulk vs
Iron Man storyline but this is only
revealed to Bruce Banner by virtue of
the fact that the that Iron Man had
directly contributed to him becoming in
the Incredible Hulk which is the reason
why Bruce Banner doesn't know the
secrets of Peter Parker as we'll discuss
later in this story likewise Peter
Parker doesn't know the secrets of how
it was at Bruce Banner actually became
the Incredible Hulk and so it seems as
though these events are contained only
to these individuals and so it's not as
if everybody everywhere knows everybody
else's Secrets is simply just that they
know the secrets that are relevant to
them but what we see here as the story
progresses is that Peter Parker learns
that he was not the only one bitten by
a spider that had that had been
radioactive and caused him to become
spider-man in the first place then in
fact there was somebody else there was a
girl who was bitten and the way it's
explained to us we're kind of able to
piece this girl's name together and we
learned her name is Cindy moon but this
girl when she's bitten is not able to
control her abilities whereas when
Spiderman was bitten he almost
immediately went out and began to
demonstrate his powers began to capture
his powers in addition we see that this
girl Cindy moon is taken before Ezekiel
as IRA a character named Ezekiel an
Ezekiel says that he can help her now
we're not going to go too in depth into
Ezekiel just because we begin to getting
into territory like more loon and totems
and Peter Parker representing a spider
on a totem and all kinds of different
nonsense when it comes to Peter Parker's
character but we see that as Peter
Parker learns this once he realizes that
he's not the only person to have been
bitten by a spider and once he learns
that Ezekiel had in effect locked Cindy
Moon away he goes on a hunt for her he
goes on this quest to find out who she
is and to try to find a way to locate
her in addition what we see is that once
he's able to locate this place where
she's at he breaks in and when he breaks
in of course he smashes down the door
and someone so forth but he's really
talking to himself and us at the same
time simply telling us that he's
familiar with this area he's familiar
with this location it's an old hideout
that belonged to Ezekiel and as he makes
his way into this location an automated
message appears from Ezekiel and Ezekiel
tells spider-man that if spider-man has
appeared here if spider-man has found
this location then that means that
Ezekiel was killed in a conflict with
more loon now again without going too
far in a more loon and the idea of
totems all this really was was a
circumstance whereby Peter Parker
represented an element of a totem and
that these totems were based on animals
they were based on creatures and that
more loon was on a hunt to kill each one
of these and to effectively consume them
and to take their powers and this was
how it was that Peter Parker and more
loon came into conflict but what we see
is that
Ezekiel says that there's a reason why
he kept this girl hidden from him
there's a reason why he kept the two of
them separated the Peter Parker
immediately cuts him off before he can
go any further and so we don't really
know what it was that happened from here
we see Peter Parker approaching the door
whereby Cindy moon is being kept being
held and he hollers for he calls for her
and she responds she says is anybody
there and he says yes he says this is
spider-man and she's kind of shocked to
to learn that Peter Parker is here
indicating to us that maybe there was
something going on with her character
that maybe she wasn't immediately handed
over to Ezekiel perhaps she was in the
public eye or she was part of public
society long enough to know who Peter
Parker was and again a lot of this has
to do with the time the sliding time
scale of various Marvel characters and
Franklin Richards existence of the
Marvel Universe and all kinds of
different things that go on but we see
that Peter Parker tells her that he's
here to get her out is he here to here
easier to save her
and that nobody should be made to live
under these kind of conditions Peter
Parker says that he knows what the code
is
but Cindy moon says not to open it she
says that if he opens the door then more
loon will come for them what we see as a
Peter Parker is able to unlock the door
and and allow her out and almost
immediately after she is a release from
her binds she attacks Peter Parker and
she tells Peter Parker that he's killed
them all that for whatever reason
they're all going to die from here we
switched to Africa and we switched to
more loon and more loon becomes aware of
the fact that the female spider
spider-woman or I guess the first
official Spider Woman to have ever
existed in Marvel Comics is I guess up
here so she's she's free and that she's
available for him to to attempt to
capture at this point we switched back
to speeder to Peter Parker and Cindy
moon and Peter Parker and Cindy moon are
of course continuing to fight one
another and she again tells him that
more loon is going to kill them that
more loon is going to not only attack
and kill both Peter Parker and Cindy
moon but everybody else that is a totem
along the the animal chain from here we
see that Peter Parker says that that
more loon is is not dead you know that
more
the Molina is not alive that more loon
is dead what we also see here is that
Cyndi moon is able to demonstrate powers
that Peter Parker doesn't have she is
much faster than Peter Parker is but on
the off side of this we learned that
Peter Parker is actually stronger and so
it's kind of this trade-off here whereby
neither of them are equal either one is
more powerful than the other they're
simply they're almost opposite sides of
the same coin but what we see is of
course once she tells him or once Peter
Parker tells her that more Lena's dead
that she embraces her freedom she
embraces the fact that she's no longer
being held captive and that she can for
the most part delve into the role that
she's created for herself or delve into
the possibility of being some kind of a
superhero
in addition we see that Peter Parker
tells her that she can't simply just run
around without having any kind of a mask
or any kind of a of an outfit that she
needs to be able to keep her personal
identity secret so that she can avoid
confrontations like Peter Parker's
experience with Wynn Stacy and so what
we see is that she fashions an outfit
for herself she fashions a costume and
what she does is she goes by the name
silk now one thing I would like you to
take personal note of a very important
note of here is that I would consider
Cindy moon to again be the first
official spider woman in Marvel Comics
and the reason why is because black hat
and Julia carpenter and various other
individuals who have adopted the role of
Spider Woman have their own powers but
they're not the result of the same spite
of the bit Peter Parker biting them this
is the first time we ever learned that
the the spite of the bit Peter Parker
bit somebody else and so a lot of people
including myself will look at Cindy moon
and say Cindy moon is the first official
Spider Woman to have existed in Marvel
Comics
now whether Marvel will actually do
anything with this whether or not she'll
have a short run or she'll be a
long-lasting character as something that
we don't know yet we don't really know
what the the grandiose plans are for her
character in terms of Marvel we simply
know that she's being introduced to us
as as possibly a replacement or maybe a
counterpart to Peter Parker is
spider-man in the Marvel Comics with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and we'll
pick up with the next video when we get
into the incredible
and we talked about the backstory
involving Tony Stark's I guess
involvement with the Incredible Hulk and
how it was that Bruce Banner became the
Hulk in the first place
so like our video on spider-man we're
not going to be going in depth into the
entire event involving Hulk vs Iron Man
and there's a couple reasons for this
the first reason is simply just time the
Hulk vs Iron Man story is for parts and
for the most part up until issue number
four all we really see is this kind of
cat-and-mouse game with the Incredible
Hulk is chasing after Iron Man and both
individuals are trying to unlock for
trying to discover what it was that it
truly happened and all these different
things taking place but the other half
of this is that we are wanting to move
forward past original sin and into
Infinity Gauntlet and so in order to
ensure that this happens we're gonna go
ahead and jump a little bit when it
comes to the Incredible Hulk vs Iron Man
story now if you're curious with the
backstory if you're interested in
knowing the kind of things that went on
and and what the relationship was like
between Bruce Banner and the incredibly
and Tony Stark then comic story and
Benny has a really good video up where
he covers a lot of this backstory stuff
but what we need to do before we get
into the original sin' revelation is we
need to jump back to May of 1962 and we
need to go over the Incredible Hulk
issue number one and Marvel's revelation
to us to how it is that Bruce Banner
became The Incredible Hulk and what we
learned here is that Bruce Banner along
with a colleague named Igor is looking
to set off or to detonate something
called the gamma bomb now the gamma bomb
was supposed to be the next step in the
weapons arsenal of the United States it
was supposed to be a bomb that was
designed to have such a high yield such
a high magnitude that were it would in
effect just scare people off people just
wouldn't want to confront the United
States because of the kind of weaponry
that's being developed here in addition
we see that a teenage kid some young kid
was able to make his way into the
testing area where the bomb was supposed
to detonate and that if this bomb goes
off while that kid is there then the kid
will be killed and so in an effort to to
ensure safety all around Bruce Banner
races off to try to rescue this young
teenage
and try to get him out of the danger
zone but what we see here is that his
colleague Igor is actually a Russian in
disguise and he's a spy for the Russian
government and so what he rationalizes
here is that he can kill Bruce Banner by
setting off the bomb prematurely and
that when Bruce Banner is in the testing
area Bruce Banner will be totally
eradicated and the egor will be the only
other person who is aware of what's
going on and how to use this gamma bomb
technology that Bruce Banner has
developed over the years from here and
we switch to the testing area and as we
can see this young kid just seems to be
sitting here playing a harmonica just
sort of hanging out and and chilling and
whatnot but what we see is that while
Bruce Banner grabs this young man and
throws him into a trench Egor presses
the fire button and the expectation here
is that this bomb is going to kill Bruce
Banner but instead what we see is that
Bruce banners body is saturated with
gamma rays his entire being is
completely filled with it and so he
survives but of course we learned that
later on this leads to him becoming the
Incredible Hulk now from here we
switched to original sin issue number 4
and what we learned here is that where
previously it was assumed that maybe you
that the the bomb going off that Igor's
involvement was the cause of Bruce
Banner becoming the Incredible Hulk that
while that was the catalyst that was the
actual action that led to it
though there's actually more to this
story and what we learned is that Tony
Stark
and Bruce Banner we're actually
colleagues at one point in time they had
worked together but the way that Marvel
has explained the fact that nobody seems
to remember this is actually a little
disappointing Marvel simply just chalks
this up to Tony Stark's alcoholism and
just says that you know because Tony
Stark was an alcohol alcohol ik because
he has blank patches in his mind he just
doesn't remember it
which if I can be a little frank here I
think is sort of lazy writing but what
we have seen previously is that general
Thunderbolt Ross who of course Bruce
Banner had approached with regards to
the gamma bomb gamma bomb project had
enlisted the aid of Tony Stark to
investigate the shield and due to an
argument that
a stark and Bruce Banner had wear by
Tony Stark said that Bruce Banner was
holding back the capabilities of the
bomb by shielding the explosion and so
what we see is that general Thunderbolt
Ross has tasked Tony Stark
with investigating the shielding to
seeing if maybe this is true to seeing
if there's a way to get the most bang
for their buck so to speak to make the
bomb as potent as possible while still
allowing it to still be controllable and
so what we see is that Tony Stark is
he's continuing to investigate this bomb
begins to talk to us about how it's just
one of these pieces went bad it's just
one of these pieces were missing it
could set off a chain reaction that
would be added absolutely catastrophic
and initially the way he explains it to
us he's kind of arguing with himself
that maybe in his drunken state he's
considering allowing this to happen he's
considering maybe removing one of these
pieces and allowing Bruce banners bomb
to screw up and possibly Bruce Banner
being either discredited or maybe even
killed in the process but we see that
Tony Stark rationalizes with himself
that Bruce Banner is his friend and that
while he may not like him very much that
he doesn't need to take the road of
effectively murdering him we also see
that again this the alcoholism of Tony's
start coming into play when he says he
doesn't care for himself too much either
but that's no reason to take out this on
on Bruce Banner what we also see is that
Tony Stark while he's continuing to
investigate the bomb comes to the
realization that the shielding that's
been placed over the bomb will actually
do the opposite of what Bruce Banner is
expecting that the shielding is going to
cause the bomb to explode on a much
higher scale instead of confining the
explosion of the bomb and so try to
think of this in terms of the damage
that could be done if you had a maybe a
grenade that you set on top of a table
and you allow the grenade to go off the
grenade would be very destructive it
would destroy a lot of different things
but if you wrapped a grenade in sheet
metal and then you allow the grenade to
go off the destruction would be even
worse and so what we see is Tony Stark
rationalizing that this is the case that
because there is too much shielding the
bomb is going to be far more destructive
than anybody thinks it is and so we see
that he begins to go through the process
of modifying the gamma bomb and he
simply modifies it in such a way to
where he removes some of the shielding
so that the explosion the destruction
won't be nearly as bad we also see him
in a little bit of a comedic way talking
about how well Bruce Banner is a
pacifist that he's able to take out are
able to make one heck of a bomb but we
also see Tony Stark again arguing with
himself in debating as to whether or not
he's actually going to tell Bruce Banner
that he's made these modifications and
that these modifications will keep Bruce
Banner safe that it will keep the
observers along with Bruce Banner from
being killed in the explosion from here
we transition back to Bruce Banner and
II and Tony Stark as the two of them are
having a conversation out in the desert
which of course is where we had picked
up before we had gotten into our
discussion on the original sin memories
but what we see here is that while Bruce
Banner in the incredibox are Bruce
Banner and Tony Stark are talking Bruce
Banner is is satisfied with his
explanation Bruce Banner doesn't realize
at least as far from far as he can tell
that Tony Stark had basically saved his
life and saved the lives of various
observers which include Betty Ross and
so we see that for the most part Bruce
Banner who was initially angry with Tony
Stark is now calm down
he now feels like it's really his fault
that he was that he became the
Incredible Hulk that it's not actually
the fault of Tony Stark but what we
learn as Bruce Banner begins to leave is
that Tony Stark didn't tell him
everything that not everything involving
the the events of Bruce Banner becoming
the Incredible Hulk
we're explained by Tony Stark to him and
what we see is that Tony Stark is in a
drunken state on his bed and he's
mulling over what he's going to say to
to Bruce Banner he activates the voice
dictation system and he begins to
effectively just speak what it is that
he wants to say in an email and what he
tells Bruce Banner is that he's fixed
his bomb that he has enabled the bomb to
to detonate the way it's expected to
removing some of the shielding in
addition
the part that is most poignant here the
part that is the most important here is
Bruce Banner I'm sorry I'm Tony Stark's
revelation of the fact that he was aware
that the possibility existed that the
saturation of gamma rays into the cells
of an organism could very well transform
that organism and this is what he tells
Bruce Banner he tells Bruce Banner that
he looked at the energy emission
spectrum and that there was all kinds of
crazy things in there and that he he
knows some individuals who have worked
with morphogenic technology and that
most likely the gamma-ray explosion will
cause a I guess a a change in the bio
matter will causing the change I call
the change in the cells of whichever
organism is exposed to that much gamma
radiation at one point in time now this
doesn't mean that Tony Stark knows that
Bruce Banner is going to become the
Incredible Hulk or that if he was
exposed to the gamma rays that he would
become the Incredible Hulk
it's simply Tony Stark telling Bruce
Banner that exposure to the gamma rays
would cause some kind of a cell mutation
would cause something to happen within
the body that could have an adverse
effect or could have a beneficial effect
and so he asked Bruce Banner to take a
second look to to take a look before he
sets off the gamma bomb but what we see
is that when Bruce Banner arrives at his
lab the next day to analyze the gamma
bomb to go over his his findings and
studies that he sees the email from Tony
Stark but that he promptly deletes it
without ever looking at it to see what
it is from here we see Tony Stark kind
of again talking to us we're talking to
himself telling us that he knows that
after he said that email that Bruce
Banner didn't look at it and the reason
why he didn't look at it is because
Bruce Banner is the Incredible Hulk and
that it would drive Bruce Banner insane
if he was informed that the only reason
why he became the Incredible Hulk is
because he didn't check an email that he
was so much like Tony Stark in the sense
that he was being so proud but from here
we're gonna bring the tie-ins to an end
we're really not gonna discuss any more
tie-ins here just because for the most
part again we want to continue on with
the original sin storyline and
eventually move forward into Infinity
Gauntlet
so before we get into our discussion
about original sin issue number four we
need to do a rehash we need to go back
and make sure that we're refreshed on
where we stand
following the events of the previous
original sin issue original sin issue
number three then with the way things
stand now what we know is that Nick Fury
is dead Nick Fury was killed by Bucky
Barnes after Nick Fury had gained the
eye of the watcher from the orb the
individual who had first appeared to us
holding the eye of the watcher and who
had exposed a multitude of secrets to
the Marvel superhero community what we
also have going on here is an
independent investigation of sorts of
course we have Wolverine and The
Incredible Hulk trying to piece things
together on their own trying to figure
out what in the world is going on but
more than that we have three groups of
superheroes who have been set on the
path of this investigation as to what
the unseen is and to who it was that
killed The Watcher by some anonymous
individual some person who we just
simply haven't been told what his
identity is yet then these groups are
Moon Knight Gomorrah and the Winter
Soldier Bucky Barnes who were
investigating space and of course they
came across a planet that had been
killed by this unknown individual but we
also had as Black Panther Emma Frost and
Scott Lang ant-man and they were
investigating the center of the earth
and they found a multitude of different
bodies that had been placed there over
the course of years and years and they
had been building up for quite some time
but again we don't know who it was that
had killed these what we have for our
last group is Doctor Strange and a
Punisher then they're investigating
extra-dimensional things they're delving
into the realms of Doctor Strange into
the various dimensions of Doctor Strange
and they're conducting their own
investigation as they come across
various bodies that have been destroyed
or bodies that have been killed by
whoever this anonymous individual
happens to be what we had also seen is
that the common theme throughout all
these groups all these investigations is
that the bodies they had been to stay
have discovered had been riddled with
gamma or radiated bullets which tells us
two things
that one gamma radiation is a lot more
potent than we thought it was and that
it is a force that can be used to kill
pretty much anything
but that also there's only one person
that we know of who is for the most part
an expert when it comes to gamma
radiation or is most commonly associated
with gamma radiation and that person is
Bruce Banner from here we're going to
start with original sin issue number
four and what we see going on is that a
frank castle and dr. strange are still
within the dimension the dimension of of
man-eating shadows and what we see is at
Frank castles reaction to dr. strange
talking about how there were only a
handful of people on this list who could
have done this is crazy talk and that he
wants dr. strange to stop but dr.
strange simply replies by saying that
it's inherent it's a part of who he is
because he's dr. strange because he
deals with strange things that craziness
is just an inherent part of his
personality but that just because he's
talking this way doesn't mean that he's
wrong and what we see Frank Castle
saying is that the reason why dr.
strange is wrong is not because of the
way he's talking but because he doesn't
know what he's talking about
from here we see dr. strange challenged
the Punisher and dr. strange tells Frank
Castle that if he is the expert on mass
murder and he is the person who for the
most part we would assume to have
actually been the cause of all this that
he would have the best explanation of to
what's most likely taking place and what
we see the Punisher replying with is
that someone has been going into the
backyard of dr. strange and killing
monsters killing his enemies and they've
effectively been doing his job for him
and been doing his job better than he
has and so Frank Castle theorizes here
that this pisses off dr. strange that it
makes him angry that maybe somebody is
more effective than he is at doing his
job and it maybe it strikes a kind of
personal chord with him but what we see
here is that Steven strange says that
would make some angry is the fact that
he's being lied to it's not necessarily
the fact that these different beings
have been destroyed what we also see
going on is that dr. strange begins to
challenge the the very basis the very
concept of the Punisher with with Frank
Castle what we most commonly see is that
when he's on his endeavors and he's
killing various individuals or he's
attempting an investigation of some kind
very few people lie to him and the
reason why is because for the most part
they know
the Frank Castle is a no-nonsense man
that he is he'd be just inclined to kill
the person that he's interrogating as
continue to let them talk and so it's in
their best interest to tell him what he
wants to know in order to continue with
their life and so we see dr. strange
using this dr. strange asks Frank Castle
if it's been so long since anybody lied
to him or is it simply that he's so used
to lying to himself that he's unable to
detect what he's being lied to and what
we see is Frank Castle countering this
and saying that the guy they're standing
on probably didn't think that he could
die of a gunshot wound but he believed
that right up until the point where he
did die which of course is Frank Castle
more or less telling dr. strange that
despite the vast powers that he
possesses he can probably be killed just
like anybody else in addition we see
that dr. strange more or less walks away
from this argument and makes the
statement that their killer has been
very busy for a very long amount of time
they've been doing this for quite some
time and that whoever this unknown
individual is is the person that set
them on this path and they knew exactly
where this path led to and that they
this under an individual wanted dr.
strange of Frank Castle to discover this
to discover this evidence of what it is
it's been taking place from here we see
the Frank Castle begins to more-or-less
I wouldn't go as far as to say reconcile
but to understand where dr. strange is
coming from and he simply replies by
asking him if he doesn't trust anybody
else and he answers his own question by
saying good he says that he that dr.
strange isn't necessarily dumb as he
thought he as dumb as he thought he was
but what we see Frank Castle doing here
is demonstrating a level of intelligence
that is actually kind of
uncharacteristic for Frank Castle not to
say that he's a dumb character but we
see him saying that the one person they
need to be talking to you right now is
the one person they trust the least
which is more or less this individual
that set them on the path of this
investigation what we also say is I'm
sorry what we also see is that Frank
Castle and presumably maybe other
members of these investigation teams
don't know about the other
investigations we see that Frank Castle
asks that or else or replies by simply
saying that if dr. strain
said there's all of us he's if he said
there's more of us than who are the
others and Doctor Strange says it if he
if Frank Castle thought that their
team-up was a little strange then wait
until he meets the rest of the group and
this is an indication to us that maybe
there are only there's only one
individual in each group that knows for
the most part everything that's going on
or the very least knows about the other
investigations that are taking place we
know the Black Panther is aware that
other investigations are taking place
because this unanimous are anonymous
individual had spoken with black panther
about the team that he had formed but we
also know now that dr. strange knows
about the other teams but we're not
really sure if Bucky Barnes is a way of
the other teams or Gamora or even Moon
Knight from here we switch back to Bucky
Barnes and what we see is that Bucky
Barnes has arrived on the blue area of
the moon
now again Bucky Barnes is currently in
possession of the eye since he had
killed Nick Fury and taken the eye from
him
but what we see as Bucky Barnes talking
into his wrist into some kind of a
communicator maybe and telling whoever
it is that is on the other side of this
communicator listening that he knows
he's out here and that he knows he can
hear him and that he's coming for him
and so we see that Bucky Barnes holds up
the head of Nick Fury and simply says
that he's bringing a friend from here we
transitioned back to Black Panther Emma
Frost and Scott Lang and what we see is
that again they're getting news reports
they're getting information to them
which tells them that tells them two
main things one that dr. Midas is
supposedly behind this event that dr.
Midas is in some way to hide into what
it is it's going on then we see that
Scott Lang chimes and by saying that
he's heard of dr. - but he's extremely
rich rich but he's extremely weird he
says that he could see him being the one
that that killed the watcher but not the
one that's killed all these different
aliens and organisms and monsters and
whatnot but then we see Emma Frost using
her experience with the Hellfire Club to
chime in and to say that when men get
bored when extremely wealthy men get
bored they'll do almost anything to ease
the boredom and so we see her talking
about how this idea of perhaps going on
a hunt for various monsters and various
individuals would be a very challenging
thing and would pile
we eliminate the boredom in the life of
this very rich and powerful man she goes
on to tell us that when she was in the
Hellfire Club presumably when she was
with Sebastian Shaw and of course jason
wyngarde and various other individuals
that she had seen them used their powers
to manipulate other individuals for
sheer enjoyment for no other reason than
the fact that they could what we also
see here is that Scott Lang tells white
panther that they're heading to the
surface that they're almost at the
surface and that they need to slow down
but we see the black panther doesn't do
it the black panther continues on at the
same speed for the most part indicating
that they're actually getting ready to
leave the planet entirely we see that
Emma Frost tries to use her ability to
read the mind of black panther but this
is unsuccessful now again as far as my
understanding goes with white panther
due to his mystical abilities and
various technologies at his disposal
he's able to disrupt the ability for
individuals to read his mind but again
this is something that I wouldn't go as
far as to say that I'm 100% sure of but
what we see black panther doing is
replying to Emma Frost to simply stay
out of there and Emma Frost describes
white Panthers mind as a bear trap
wrapped in barbed wire that someone set
on fire which indicates to us that a
black panther does indeed have some kind
of mental conditioning that keeps
telepaths from being able to read his
mind what we also see is Black Panther
replying to a question of Scott Lang the
Scott Lang asked Black Panther what it
is that he knows that they don't and
Black Panther says nothing he says
that's what worries him because for the
most part Black Panther is one of the
most intelligent beings on the planet
Earth and so he's able to decipher clues
and evidence and so on far ahead of
anybody else due to his vast experience
with technology and with science and
just his overall intellect but the fact
that he doesn't know anything more than
anybody else does gives him cause for
concern but what we see is that their
ship is actually heading into space now
their ship is traveling towards the moon
from here we transition back to wolf
rain and the Incredible Hulk and what we
see is that they've arrived at the
vengers tower where they've learned that
Nick Fury is dead and Nick Fury of
course has been beheaded but what we see
is that when
Wolverine uses his ability to track
sense that he did he realizes this is
Bucky Barnes now again this is one of
the elements of Wolverine that's very
important to his character that when he
picks up a scent of a person he never
forgets it and so from the first time
that he ever smelled Bucky Barnes he's
able to track him and he can recognize
his scent no matter where he goes which
is the reason why Wolverine is able to
determine that this is Bucky Barnes
rather than some random person and what
we see Wolverine realizing here is that
he thought that Bucky Barnes had been
dead but apparently he's alive or that
he never really liked him that much in
the first place but then the other
question becomes how was he able to kill
Nick Fury how was this able to happen
but before he's able to get too much
further into his questioning we see the
Doctor Strange and and Frank Castle up
here at this point we see Wolverine
beginning to plead with Doctor Strange
and Frank Castle telling them that it's
not what it looks like that they weren't
the ones that hit he and the Incredible
Hulk weren't the ones that killed Nick
Fury and what we see is Doctor Strange
may be perceiving the fact that that
seems to be the case then it looks like
Wolverine and The Incredible Hulk killed
Nick Fury and because of all the lies
that they've experienced because of the
fact that they're wrapped up in this
whodunit mystery of sorts and they don't
really trust anybody they're erring on
the side of caution and assuming that
Wolverine and the Incredible Hulk
were the ones who killed Nick Fury from
here we see Doctor Strange use his
powers to bind Wolverine now again these
are the the Crimson wraps I think of
asset auric of Sid Iraq and again if you
guys remember our discussion about
Doctor Strange we had talked about the
octet ins and various things and while
the SID Iraq had lent his gym to the
juggernaut for power we also know that
Doctor Strange derived some of his
abilities from from sidorak himself and
so this is one of those powers where
he's able to wrap Wolverine in an
unescapable bind and Wolverine simply
just can't get away from here we see the
Incredible Hulk begins to go on the
offensive and encounter to this we see
that Frank Castle shoots at at the
Incredible Hulk with a multitude with a
barrage of bullets
of course the Incredible Hulk doesn't
really care he thinks is sort of funny
that Frank Castle would reply in such a
way and he asked Frank Castle if that
was supposed to hurt and Frank Castle
says
no but what we learn here is that the
bullets were miniature explosives that
had pierced the skin of the Incredible
Hulk although not killed him however
what we see Frank Castle doing is
detonating these bullets and the
detonation sends the Incredible Hulk
flying out of Avengers Tower and out
into the streets below from here we see
Frank Castle sort of investigating the
the death of Nick Fury and maybe talking
to himself a bit when he says that
there's no such thing as retired they're
simply just dead we also see him discuss
how the Incredible Hulk may very well be
an idiot but that trick is only gonna
work one time and so he tells Doctor
Strange they need to work fast they need
to find some way to either do their
conductor investigation as fast as
possible or to simply just leave now
what we see is Doctor Strange again
saying that he's working on this that
he's trying to find some way to figure
out what's going on we see Franco a
friend Castle asked if the body is worth
a closer look and Doctor Strange says no
that it's not indicating to us that
maybe dr. strange knows something that
we don't know which of course is
something that we'll learn later on in
this story from here we see that Doctor
Strange uses the eye of agamotto the
third eye and he's able to to realize
that the orb is within the Avengers
Tower and it's currently being held
prisoner and what we see is him saying
that the orb is somebody with which they
need to to speak with from here we see
the Doctor Strange and the Punisher are
with the orb and the orb asks if they're
here to kill him and Doctor Strange says
no but Frank Castle says maybe what we
also see going on here is the orb saying
that somebody stole his eye and we see
that again dr. strange replies by saying
that somebody stole a lot more than
simply just his eye but what we saw is
I'm sorry what we see here is that the
orb replies by simply saying that that
he did that some individual did send
them that this unknown individual this
mysterious man this anonymous benefactor
is the one behind all of this but we see
the Doctor Strange who apparently
doesn't realize what's going on saying
that no one's sent them that they're
simply just here for the truth to which
we see the orb replying that the truth
is they don't know who they're working
for they have no real idea
what's going on that they haven't seen
this anonymous man not truly and we see
that the Orbitz replies to this
individual as the unseen now again this
is very important here and the reason
why is because with this idea of the
unseen this is how we're going to see
this story play out that this individual
is referred to as the unseen this
individual the actions that he had
committed in the past are referred to as
his original sins and so this for the
most part seems to be the way this story
is based around but what we see is the
orb realizing or I guess telling us that
this unknown individual this mysterious
man is the one that had killed all these
different organisms both in other
dimensions as well as the center of the
earth and in the vastness of space that
he's been doing this for quite some time
from here we see the Incredible Hulk has
returned to the building albeit not to
the immediate vicinity of Doctor Strange
the orb Wolverine and and Frank Castle
and so we see that that Frank Castle
puts his bullet to the eye of the orb
and tells the orbit simply just start
talking or he's gonna see what happens
when he goes blind what we see is that
the or begins to say that the problem
here is that the eye seems to be calling
him it seems to be communicating with
him which maybe gives us the sort of
idea that the relationship between the
orb and the eye can best be compared to
Gollum and the ring from Lord of the
Rings but what we see going on here is
that maybe the orb has formed some kind
of relationship with the eye the orb
says that if he listens hard enough if
he tries hard enough the I can find him
that he can he can locate where the eye
is at but he says the problem here is
that the eye is going to want to show
them the truth once they find it and
they're going to want to look but that
some things that simply just don't need
to be seen from here we transition back
to Black Panther Scott Lang and Emma
Frost and what we see is that a new set
of coordinates had been determined and
that black panther is sending them on a
new heading now what this new heading is
is something that we don't know just
this second but what we learn is that
while Black Panther won't necessarily
tell Emma Frost and Scott Lang what it
is it's going on immediately that he
begins to to actually explain that it
begins to take a step away from keeping
things routed and mystery from his team
and actually offers an explanation and
what he says is that the call that he
got was a call on behalf of this
anonymous individual if you guys
remember our discussion in the early
videos of original sin we had talked
about after the death of the watcher
that some unknown individual had
contacted black panther and sent him
various forms of information various
documents which led to this
investigation then what we had seen is
that by Panther had begun the process of
triangulated the signal triangulating
where it was it had come from and so
what we learn is that this had come from
a satellite this had come from a
satellite that had been totally
uncharted that had been undetected no
one knows when it launched where it
launched or how it got up there it's
simply just there and so this is very
disconcerting to Black Panther and to
other superheroes because no one really
knows what's going on inside here or
what the purpose of this satellite is
from here we transition to Black Panther
and Scott Lang and Emma Frost
docking inside the satellite and we're
docking on the satellite rather and what
we learn here is that again as they're
investigating as they're looking around
that despite the fact that watcher has
been gone that there's already always
somebody watching here there's always
somebody looking and so it could just
very well be that they're walking into a
trap but they're the next individuals to
be killed on this list of dead beings
but what we see is that somebody is
looking at them
somebody is monitoring them and
presumably has a gun pointed at them and
what we learn here is that this person
is Frank castle at Frank Castle tells
Black Panther Scott Lang and Emma Frost
to keep their hands up to not make any
moves and we see him talking to each
individual in turn telling them what not
to do detail Scott Lane that if he
shrinks it he'll shoot him and he tells
Emma Frost that if she tries to read his
mind that he's going to shoot her in the
head
and from here we see that Doctor Strange
appears and tells T'Challa tells Black
Panther that he would much rather that
Frank castles hand twitch then dr.
Strange's hand twitch just because dr.
strange will be capable of far more
incredible feats than Black Panther when
I'm sorry then Frank Castle would but
what we see is him also asking Black
Panther whose side is he on which side
has he chosen here what we also see is
why Panther and Doctor Strange
conversing directly where Doctor Strange
and Black Panther begin to sort of
debate with one another Black Panther
says he's not sure what side they're on
that they're trying to figure that out
and what we see is Doctor Strange saying
that's the same thing that's the same
thing they're trying to do trying to do
that they're trying to figure out who's
the right side they're trying to figure
out what in the world is going on here
we see him asking Black Panther what it
is that he found that led him here and
black panther says it's the same thing
that Doctor Strange found a series of
lies and a lot of bodies and we see that
he says he doesn't know who who began
all of this he doesn't know where all
this started but he does know where it
is that all the lies began from here we
transitioned to again Doctor Strange
telling these individuals telling Scott
Lang and Emma Frost and black panther
that they managed to get here by virtue
of the orb doing its best to communicate
or to track the location of the eye what
we also see is that the orb is no longer
as Doctor Strange explains it is no
longer in possession of the Watchers
eyes that the Watchers eye is now
missing but no one really knows where it
is
what we also see the orb saying here is
that the eye is screaming that the eye
is near the eye is relatively close to
where they're at but we see again Black
Panther Doctor Strange pretty much
everybody except for the or arguing
amongst themselves saying that the orb
has to have had something to do with it
because he admits being on the moon and
he was in possession of the Watchers eye
and so all evidence points to the fact
that the orb was the one who killed the
watcher but what we see is the or more
or less stopping everybody and saying
that the eye is here but that the eye is
not alone and what we see going on is
that Bucky Barnes is standing on a
catwalk of sorts and peering down on
everybody
monitoring everybody and what he says is
that he doesn't trust anybody but he
says that in a minute or so the feeling
is going to be mutual what we see Bucky
Barnes doing is jumping down and Bucky
Barnes simply says begins to communicate
with them telling them that he has Nick
Fury's head and the or view I'm sorry
that Emma Frost replies by saying is he
the one that killed Nick Fury but what
we see is again this sort of argument
going on between Frank Castle and and
Bucky Barnes where Frank Castle says he
never really liked him they never really
cared for him and that Bucky Barnes
needs to get on his knees before Frank
Castle shoots him and Bucky Barnes who
of course has prodigious skill that is
beyond anything Frank Castle has replies
to Frank Castle by saying that that he's
not a dope pusher that he's not of
afraid he's not afraid of a man that
can't protect his own children and again
sort of a taunting Frank Castle here but
what we see going on is Bucky Barnes
says that the reason why he's here is
because he's in possession of the head
of Nick Fury and the head of Nick Fury
is the reason why he showed up at this
location although at this point we don't
exactly know how or why that's happened
but what we see is that before he can
continue that another ship docks with
the the satellite and our Gamora almost
immediately begins running in and
attacking Bucky Barnes from here we see
that Bucky Barnes and Gamora engage in
this extremely deadly cat-and-mouse
fight where Bucky Barnes is able to stay
on the defensive and avoid the the
killing blows of Gamora look at more
abuse Bucky Barnes at a traitor due to
the fact that Bucky Barnes had
previously just a Batoche their ship and
abandoned them on the on the dead planet
from here we again see that Moon Knight
arrives and moon knife simply explains
to everybody that Winter Soldier had
blown up their ship that Bucky Barnes
had left them stranded in deep space and
so Gamora Buse him as a traitor and that
they had to catch a ride in order to get
back here with a friend of theirs and
what we learned is that the individual
that gave them a ride is actually rocket
racoon now as far as I know this is the
only real appearance that we see Rocket
Raccoon in the original sense story from
this point going forward we hadn't
really seen him previously and it was
interesting to see his character arrive
in original sin because what we get is
this really cool
confrontation with with rocket racoon
and the Punisher but again we see the
Gamora and and Bucky Barnes are
continuing to fight and for the most
part what we see going on here with
regards to the set of events is this
breakdown of teamwork we see all these
individuals all these superheroes who
have arrived on this satellite and all
of them are mistrusting each other none
of them trust anyone and so they're all
suspicious of everybody else and this is
kind of the scenario you would expect
when so many people who possess so many
formidable abilities all exist in the
same place but nobody trusts anyone in
addition what we see is that Bucky
Barnes holds up the head of Mick theory
as Gamora goes to effectively attack him
and when she does she strikes the head
of Nick Fury and the head of Nick Fury
is revealed to be a robot and this was
when we learned that this Nick Fury was
actually a life model decoy that this
was not the Nick Fury that we're
familiar with and that this is the most
sophisticated life model decoy that
Bucky Barnes had ever seen Bucky Barnes
had used the chip within the head of the
life model decoy to bring himself here
to determine the origins of where it
came from and that his origins came from
that satellite from here we see that
again that Emma Frost goes as far as to
say that all this started with Nick Fury
that that that's what Black Panther had
said indicating to us that maybe Black
Panther I'm sorry that Emma Frost was
able to read the mind of Black Panther
or the Black Panther had simply just
said it at a previous point in time in
addition we see Black Panther
rationalizing that none of them were
told the truth that they were that
they're they're not all here by
coincidence that this anonymous
individual had effectively given them
all different pieces of information but
all the information that had been given
to them would inevitably lead them to
where they are right now which is the
location of this satellite from here we
see Emma Frost replying by saying this
doesn't make any sense that none of them
were working for Nick Fury or at least
they didn't think they were working for
Nick theory but then we see that the
doors open and we see some persons
saying that that they still are that
they still are working for Nick Fury at
which point we see Nick theory and what
we see here is that Nick theory is an
odd man
and that Nick Fury is much much older
than we had been expected to believe in
addition he's currently surrounded by
several life model decoys of Nick Fury
and so this is a very puzzling
circumstance to us we don't really know
what's going on here all we know at this
point is that Nick Fury is an old man
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
in the next video we'll picked up with
what's happened we'll pick up with the
backstory of Nick Fury with what have
been going on with this whole origin so
original sin issue number five is going
to bring an answer to a lot of questions
that we guys that we have one of the
most common questions being what is the
unseen what is that referring to and how
is it the Nick Fury ties and all of this
now in order to make this video make
sense I would highly suggest that you
guys go back and watch my discussion on
Nick Fury and the reason why is because
that video will give us Nick Fury as
he'd been presented by Marvel Comics up
until this point and so what this video
will do is fill in the blanks it'll tell
us what Nick Fury had been doing on the
other side of that video what he had
been doing when he wasn't appearing in
Marvel Comics when he wasn't a part of
any major storyline now what we see
going on as the story begins to take off
is that Nick Fury is starting
immediately after his discussion with
the superheroes at the end of original
sin' issue number four and what he tells
us is that in order to make this make
sense we have to go back to 1958 in
Kansas then what we see here is that
Nick Fury along with several other
soldiers is fighting some kind of
invading alien race they are breaking
into the planet Earth by way of a portal
for whatever their intentions or goals
happen to be now Nick Fury at this point
is part of Army Intelligence and so this
is shortly after a Nick Fury has been
introduced to us in the Marvel Comics as
part of the military but again if you
recall our discussion about Nick Fury we
had talked about how there came a point
whereby Marvel was publishing two
instances Marvel was published in Nick
Fury are publishing Nick Fury when he
was in World War two but they were also
publishing his character when he was a
part of the CIA and this takes place in
between that what we see going on here
is that
fury along with these soldiers while
they're fighting these various aliens
are doing the best they can but for the
most part they're almost entirely
outnumbered they're almost entirely
outmatched just due to the technology at
the disposal of these various alien
races in addition we see some kind of an
explosion when the grenade goes off and
what we see going on here is that as a
result of this explosion almost all of
Nick Fury's team is killed and the
aliens are continuing to advance out of
their portal from here we see that Nick
Fury for the most part begins to embrace
the most likely possibility that he will
die that the planet Earth will most
likely be taken over by these aliens and
that there really won't be a whole lot
that anybody can do about it Nick Fury
tells us how during this time they had
fought various aliens here and there
they had fought different organisms and
whatnot
but he had never seen an alien invasion
on this scale before he was totally
unprepared for it but what we see is
that at the last minute an unknown
individual appears and begins destroying
the forces of these aliens in addition
he began saying things like the package
has been delivered and tells someone
named Howard to do it now we don't
really know what this means that we
don't really know who he's referring to
or who this individual is and for the
most part in terms of his name he's not
extremely important but what is
important here is the rule that he plays
in the Marvel Universe what we see here
with Nick Fury's reaction is he really
doesn't know what to do he says that if
this individual is part of Army
Intelligence maybe or part of the Armed
Forces that he's way above Nick Fury's
pay grade in addition we see that as
this individual is fighting various
aliens that he is injured and when he's
injured the result is that he's injured
in a mortal way Nick Fury runs to his
side and realized that he's been impaled
and Nick Fury ah tells him try not to
move he tells them to stay still the
response from this individual to Nick
Fury is that if Nick Fury is saying this
then most likely his injury is mortal
Nick Fury says that he's seen worse but
this individual replies by saying
haven't they all in addition this guy
says that he always thought it was going
to be the scrolls that would do him man
not this unknown race of aliens
and we see that he begins to warn the
experior to tell make fury to watch out
for the scrolls because one day they're
liable to do something but before he's
able to tell him he begins to struggle
and sort of begin to succumb to his
injuries in addition what we also see
Nick Fury saying is that if this
individual has somebody to write to if
he has somebody that he wants to pass a
letter to then he should do it now and
Nick Fury will deliver that letter for
him but this individual says that the
only people that are waiting for him are
the people that he'll be seeing almost
immediately when he dies and those are
the people that will see him in hell
most presumably due to the actions that
he's committed or possibly the the
people that he's killed what we also see
going on is that the portal has for the
most part been totally destroyed but on
the other side of this portal is some
kind of again alien race and Nick Fury
begins to reflect on this Nick Fury says
that he didn't really know what to do in
this whole situation that he was simply
just sitting in Kansas in 1958 with a
dead man in his arms steering in an
alien portal that had been totally
destroyed and didn't was really trying
to make sense of it all he said that you
know of course he saw a different alien
screaming and so on and that you know
while they were being killed that in the
end it was just strange that it was
something that he wasn't really wasn't
really used to that he wasn't really
able to deal with because he'd never
experienced anything like that before we
see that in the end this individual
succumbs to his injuries but then we see
that another unknown person runs up and
he says that the the bomb has been used
is going to make him make a small
fortune for him in addition he refers to
this unknown man as woody and this is
when we learned that this individuals
name is Woodward McCord or at least we
learn it later on and what we see going
on is that Nick Fury immediately stands
up and points a gun at this unknown
individual this on an individual tells
Nick Fury that he's a good guy that he's
not here to hurt anybody and Nick Fury
thinks that he begins to recognize him
but then we see this unknown individual
sees the body of woody and he asked
woody or asked Nick Fury if woody is
dead Nick Fury says yes and as a result
this man introduces himself to Nick Fury
what he says is that his name is Howard
Stark and begins to say that he believes
they may have met before
but before he can say anything else Nick
Fury cuts him off and asks him who is
this man that just died to save the
world in addition we see that from here
Nick Fury and Howard Stark are
travelling to some unknown destination
and Howard Stark begins explaining what
it is has been going on what he tells
Mike Fury here is that this wasn't the
first time that the planet's been
invaded by aliens
he says that this is actually far from
the first time he says for every
encounter like the one that's been
experience for every encounter whereby
aliens are able to step foot on the
planet Earth there had been dozens more
whereby that had never happened where
the aliens had been destroyed before
they could ever arrive here and he said
he was all done by because of men like
woodrow McCord now what he says is that
would Woodrow McCord is the man on the
wall more or less that he is the man
that stands between absolute destruction
and the ability for humanity to continue
existing now at the moment we don't
really know what this means but what
Howard Stark tells us here is that
inside this facility that they've
arrived at there are various forms of
technology here this facility actually
appears to be quite advanced and he
tells Mike Fury that this is the domain
of the man on the wall and that the man
on the wall doesn't answer to anybody
the man on the wall does not answer to
any kind of authority a group he doesn't
answer to any kind of federal government
or any kind of a national government
that he answers only to the people of
the planet Earth and that his only
mission is only role is to ensure that
any kind of a force whether internal
from the planet Earth itself or external
beyond the planet earth or even
extra-dimensional does not succeed in
bringing him into a life or bringing it
and into life on the planet Earth and so
what he asked Nick theory is whether or
not he would be interested in becoming
the new man on the wall to take the role
of Woodrow McCord what we see here is
that Nick Fury takes his assignment
without question Nick Fury accepts that
without any kind of regard and decides
to accept the offer of being the man on
the wall and what Nick Fury tells us
here is that for him he had always been
a soldier in a spy at least as far as he
could remember and so for him this was
pretty much the same thing he was simply
just on a much
your scale in addition we see that the
time eventually comes when Nick Fury
becomes the director of shield and what
he tells us here is that while he was
the director of shield that his role as
the man on the wall was still a part of
his life this was something that he
still had going on and so again this is
something that Nick Fury had been doing
the entire time that he had been in in
existence in Marvel Comics after the
events of world war 2 and so this is
something that Marvel had never told us
this is something that Marvel had never
explained to us directly in addition
what we also see is that Nick Fury is
using life model decoys which is an
indication to us that Nick Fury of
course as far as his first encounters
what the scrolls go is most likely an
event that took place between the Kree
squirrel invasion and the events of Nick
Fury versus shield now whether or not
this means that the most likely scenario
here is that one came before the other
there's something that we're not
entirely sure of because in a lot of
ways Marvel is sort of bad when it comes
to chronology in terms of establishing
dates we really kind of have to piece it
together and we have to make sense of it
on our own especially when you're when
you're dealing with sliding timescales
and the actions of characters like
Franklin Richards and so on but what we
learn here is that Nick Fury is
interrogating a scroll and Nick Fury is
attempting to gain some kind of
information from it now we don't really
know why but what we see here is that
Nick Fury is presumably trying to attain
whatever it is that he needs by using
physical force in order to to force this
information out of this scroll from here
we transition to New York City then what
we learn here is that Nick Fury is again
fulfilling his role as the man on the
wall and observing a possible threat in
some being that has appeared and is a
radioactive being that could most likely
cause a multitude of different kinds of
havoc or could at the very least become
a danger to life on the planet Earth but
what we see here is that Nick Fury while
he's now using gamma bomb bullets while
he's now using bullets that are modeled
after Bruce banners gamma bomb
experiment has a change of heart and
decides not to shoot this individual and
what we learn here is that this
individual is in fact
Piderman indicating to us that nick 3
was doing this around the time the
spider-man first appeared in Marvel
Comics which again gives us this sort of
strange explanation gives us this sort
of a strange timescale we're not really
sure if this explanation as Nick Fury is
giving it to us is going in a
chronological order or if he's simply
just kind of bouncing around all over
the place from here we see that Nick
Fury is explaining to us this entire
concept of what it means to be the man
on the wall and Nick Fury is telling us
that for every single conflict that it
ever happened
for every event that had ever taken
place involving the planet Earth this
has simply happened because Nick Fury
wasn't able to stop it that the secret
invasion that the kree-skrull war the
arrival of Galactus and the Silver
Surfer the very first instance of a
space bound character having being
affordable enough of a threat to the
planet Earth
the instances of the maximum security
storyline whereby Ron and the accuser is
the ruler of the planet Earth as its
turned into a prison planet these had
all taken place because Nick Fury wasn't
able to stop that threat but that for
every single one of these events that
had happened there had been dozens that
had gone on here there have been dozens
of instances whereby this had taken
place where these threats had been
destroyed before they could actually
reach the planet earth before they could
reach their maturity in addition what we
see here is that while Nick Fury tells
us that Howard Stark and various other
individuals almost anybody who knew that
he was the man on the wall had long
since been dead that while he believed
he was the only person who actually knew
everything that was going on but there
was one other person who had seen
everything and that person was who
watching The Watcher which tells us that
this is the unseen this is what Marvel's
referring to when they say the unseen
and the reason why it's called the
unseen astana the earthbound superheroes
or even anybody else in the universe
aside from The Watcher knew what was
going on but also because we as the
reader didn't know what was going on we
had no idea that any of this was taking
place and so for us it was unseen it'll
be something that we were entirely
unaware of from here we transitioned
back to Nick Fury in the current time
and Nick Fury tells the
that's why they're here he tells them
that this is the reason why they've all
arrived in this place and he asks them
if they have any questions what we see
is these superheroes dealing with them
in their own way dealing with this news
in the best way they know how we see
that dr. strange says that this doesn't
make sense that when Nick Fury is
confessing to can't be true because this
isn't the Nick Fury that he knows but
the question that has to be asked here
is has dr. strange ever actually dealt
with the real Nick theory or is every
instance where he's met Nick Fury been
Nick Fury using a life model decoy has
it been Nick Fury simply hiding in on a
satellite near the moon and dr. strange
and various other superheroes all
talking to life model decoys which seems
to be the case it seems to be that ever
since the introduction of life model
decoys and the Marvel Comics that no one
has ever actually talked to Nick Fury
that everybody has been communicating
with life model decoys all this time but
again this is some of the Marvel doesn't
really go into a deep explanation about
what we see here is of course the
Punisher saying he doesn't see a problem
with it but then we also see the orb
telling us that Nick Fury isn't
explaining everything but before he can
get to what it is that Nick Fury is not
explaining he begins to succumb to the
expanse knowledge that he had gained by
manipulating the eyes of the watcher and
so as a result he goes into shock
from here we transitioned to the
remaining superheroes beginning to again
try to absorb this information try to
absorb what's been going on here and
black panther speaks up and says that he
has a question for Nick theory and what
he asks him is what happened to the
watcher Nick Fury replies here by simply
saying that the watcher died and that
now he supposes his turn with that being
said this brings an end to original sin
issue number 5 and what we'll see with
issue number 6 is this continuation of
this story we'll find out that there's
actually a lot more going on here than
we were initially led to believe and
that Nick Fury despite the fact that he
pretends as though he's not really sure
what's going on with the watcher that he
actually has quite a bit of knowledge in
terms of what it was that happened
wotcher so as the original sin event
begins to wind down the series begins to
come to a close what we see here is that
there's going to be an answering of
questions more specifically Nick Fury is
going to give us a little more
information regarding regarding his
relationship with The Watcher now for
the most part he's not going to answer
the question of Black Panther directly
that is to say what did Nick Fury have
to do with the death of the watcher but
we're more or less gonna get an answer
to this question at the end of the comic
in addition Nick Fury is going to
explain to us why it is that he's so old
now what it is that it happened to him
and we're gonna get a better
understanding of just what it is that
Nick Fury is capable of and what we see
going on as the story begins to open up
is that the orb is somehow transforming
something is happening to him and he
doesn't quite know what it is he simply
just describes it as his insides being
on fire we see Doctor Strange reacting
to this and asking what it is is
happening to the orb and where it is
that the Nick Fury life model decoys are
taking him that he's a witness to murder
and that he needs to stay there so that
he can be questioned properly we see
that Bucky Barnes replies by saying
they're not taking him anywhere that
they're going to keep him here until
people start getting some answers and of
course we see Moon Knight say the Bucky
really has no grounds here because Bucky
had destroyed his ship what we also see
going on is that why Panther continues
to create this case continues to ask
this pressing question of Nick Fury of
what is it that he did to The Watcher
what happened to The Watcher why is it
that some of Nick Fury's
gamma-irradiated bullets were dug out of
the skull of the watcher and what Nick
Fury tells us here is that his
relationship with the watcher was
something that was questionable it was a
circumstance whereby
neither of them really liked each other
due to the very basis of the Watchers
existence and what it is that he does
then the fact that Nick Fury almost felt
like the watcher was hounding him that
the watcher was constantly monitoring
him and waiting for him to presumably
die and what we get here is a flashback
to a few weeks ago and what this
flashback tells us is two main things
the first thing is that the age
difference between Nick Fury a few weeks
ago and Nick Fury at the current time is
Sigma
freaking indicating that Nick Fury has
aged by decades over the course of a few
weeks what he also tells us here is that
Nick Fury appears to be dying Nick Fury
appears to be succumbing to the fact
that he's aging rapidly and so his body
is catching up with the fact that he's
growing old very very fast but what we
also see here is that the watcher is
watching him that who watched The
Watcher is simply just hovering in his
presence but again the watcher doesn't
really say anything so we don't know
what his motives are we don't know if
he's simply just waiting for a nephew to
die we don't really know what the case
is here and I've been in most part The
Watcher only appears in times of major
upheaval major instances where there's
going to be some sort of catastrophic
earthbound event and so the death of
Nick Fury could very well trigger this
we're not exactly sure what this means
but what we learn here is that Nick Fury
says that if the Watchers watching him
and that must mean that it's inevitable
that he's going to die but Nick Fury
refuses to Nick Fury refuses to accept
the fact that he's going to die here he
said that he simply just has too much
more to do that he's not going to die at
the feet of the watcher presumably
because of the fact that he hates the
watcher would feel like maybe it's some
sort of acquiescence he says that his
works not done that there's so much to
do that he has to protect the world no
matter what the cost is even to himself
and so what we get is this transition
back to the current day and Nick Fury
simply tells Bucky Barnes and others
listening that he's dying that the
Infinity formula that had existed within
his body is now used up now Nick Fury
previously did have extra batches of the
Infinity formula but this had simply
been used by I believe Bucky Barnes in
order for Nick Fury to assist in Bucky
Barnes staying alive due to some
injuries that he had received and so for
Nick Fury right now there's no escape
there's no getting away from the
inevitable outcome that he is going to
die of old age he says that every
morning he wakes up that he's just a
little bit older and then he doesn't
think he has much longer what we also
see here is Doctor Strange kind of
challenging this dr. strange asking Nick
Fury if this is some kind of deathbed
confession that he recruited all of
these individuals that he brought them
all along strung them along on these
series of Investigations only for Nick
for them to realize that Nick Fury was
the person who had been committing all
these crimes and that maybe this was
simply a cry for her
this was Nick Fury trying to get
everybody to notice what it was that he
has done Nick Fury says this isn't
really the case he says that none of
them are here by chance that all of them
are here with the exception of rocket
racoon that all of them are here because
of their capabilities because Nick Fury
specifically chose them which is the
reason why they were organized and it
kind of teams that they were he says
that some of these individuals are his
friends that some he only knows by
reputation and thus some of them owe
debts while others don't owe him
anything they're simply just individuals
that he considered to have been capable
of coming along for whatever this
investigation would eventually yield he
also speaks directly to Black Panther
saying that some of them are without a
doubt the smartest and most capable
people on the face of the earth and what
he says is that the reason why he
brought them on this investigation is
not because he wanted to be caught is
not so that so he could be stopped so
that he could be replaced is his
argument he wants one of them to step
forward he wants one of them to take on
the role of being the man on the wall or
even the woman on the wall someone who
is going to protect the planet Earth
from this idea of some kind of external
or internal threat that would challenge
the way of life on the planet Earth what
we see here is a transition we see that
we now join Captain America Black Widow
Wolverine and Iron Man as they are
investigating the body that was
discovered after Bucky Barnes had killed
Nick Fury and what they see here is that
this is a life model decoy and it's not
actually Nick Fury Tony Stark also goes
as far as to say that it's the most
sophisticated life model decoy that he
had ever seen we see Captain America
reaction to this by simply saying that
he can't believe that he was fooled by
Mick Fury like this that they had spoken
with this life model decoy and had
dinner with a life model decoy a few
nights ago and so the fact of a life
model decoy was so true that it seemed
so I guess exact and really had all the
many reasons of Nick Fury down is a
testament to how far the life model
decoy project has come in addition we
see Black Widow asking the question that
if Nick Fury is not dead then where is
he that he's getting under them sorry
she's getting a dozen different
emergency numbers for Nick Fury that
she's not contacting them but that
nothing's happening he's not answering
any of them that
all his known safe houses are empty and
so the question becomes what's going on
here what is taking place in this entire
event but we also see his Wolverine
saying that the Punisher and Doctor
Strange are off the reservation the
various other individuals are no longer
conducting their investigations and that
the The Punisher had shot the Incredible
Hulk through a wall and he says that
this is a kind of operation that is
indicative of something that Nick Fury
would run this is the kind of thing that
Nick Fury would would in fact direct and
so what we see is that Captain America
asks Iron Man if he has the ability to
track down where this life model decoy
came from Iron Man attempts to - more or
less I guess can be accessed the
circuitry or to somehow tap into the the
computer chip and the mind of the life
model decoy but when he does the life
model decoy explodes what we see here is
Black Widow asking what that was and
Iron Man replies by saying that it was
some kind of a self defense mechanism
this was designed to activate should the
life model decoy ever be breached in
terms of its via the breachers attempt
to access its internal workings or even
its computer chip and so what we see is
that a Tony Stark says that before I
blew up that it has sent a signal and
that he's able to trace the signal and
he says that everybody needs to pack
their oxygen tanks because they're going
into space from here we see Captain
America telling everybody they need to
assemble whoever they can't they need to
assemble virtually all forms of the
Avengers all the Avengers that currently
have that do exist or currently have
existed in the Marvel Universe need to
be brought together and he simply says
this by Avengers Assemble from here we
transition back to Nick Fury on the
space station along with very other
various other superheroes and of course
we pick up with him with the explanation
of Nick Fury and him telling them that
he wants one of them to be the last man
or woman on the wall and what we see a
Scott Lang replying to the Scott Lang
finds are very hard to believe that he's
somebody who would be capable of being
the man on the wall that for whatever
reason he doesn't seem to possess the
kind of fortitude or the willingness to
kill that would be necessary to play
this role we see that Nick Fury telling
Scott Lane not to doubt himself that
Scott Lang has the ability to carry out
this kind of a role even if he doesn't
miss
we believe it himself in addition we see
that dr. strange says that he thinks
that maybe the physical conditioning of
Nick Fury has affected his mind that for
whatever reason he's not necessarily
functioning the way that he's supposed
to he's somehow maybe looking at things
weird he says there's no need for this
kind of a role to be played out that the
superheroes have fought various foes day
in and day out and they've succeeded in
defeating pretty much all of them and
while some weren't defeated immediately
they were to feed it in a long run but
what we see a Nick Fury doing is
replying to this by saying that someone
who's been and had the kind of
experience that the Doctor Strange has
had really shouldn't be this naive and
that the fact that Nick Fury was out
there being the man on the wall and
disjoined the the foes that Nick I'm
sorry that dr. strange and these
individuals weren't even aware of is a
testament to the fact that one they
don't understand the bigger picture and
to his actions allowed them to be naive
his actions allowed them to play this
role of saying that they defeated pretty
much anybody not realizing they hadn't
defeated all the foes that were out
there from here we see that Black
Panther goes as far as to say that he's
going to ask Nick Fury one last time
he's going to ask Nick Fury who killed
the watcher from here we see that Nick
Fury realizes that one of the life model
decoys the life model decoy that was
accessed by Iron Man Captain America
Black Widow and Wolverine had self
destructed and so he says they're simply
not much time left that they're going to
have to hurry things along and so what
we see is that he uses his walking stick
to electrocute Bucky Barnes from here we
see the other life model decoys activate
and they begin to turn guns on these
superheroes but we also see going on is
Nick Fury taking the eye of the watcher
from Bucky Barnes and we see that again
Doctor Strange says that Nick Fury needs
to stop this that Nick Fury needs to
understand that what he's doing what
he's doing here is an effect turning
arms against the superheroes and that
there's no possible way that he could
succeed here but what he says is that he
has thought about this he's thought
about this for a very long time that
he's going to die and that the job still
needs to be done he said that he has a
world to protect and that's exactly what
he's going to do
we also see is that Nick Fury says that
before he dies before this event comes
to an end that hopefully one of these
superheroes will be able to understand
the role that needs to be played and
they will undertake the role of being
the man on the wall at this point we see
that again
Black Panther says that if that's the
way it's going to be then that's fine he
said that he tried to reason with Nick
Fury he tried to get an expiry to
discuss what it was it happened with The
Watcher dying of his own accord but the
fact that he chose not to it means that
he now has to take some kind of physical
action which he does and we see the
superheroes begin to attack the life
model decoys from here we jumped to -
Nick Fury as he's reentering his I guess
going back into his laboratory and what
we see is that he approaches the orb and
the orb says that he thinks he's
beginning to change that he's like a
Calla pillar a caterpillar with an
eyeball for a head and that he's
changing into something new now whether
this is true or not as something that we
don't know we don't really know what it
does this taking place with the orb all
we know is that for some reason he's
reacting to the eyes of the watcher in a
way that nobody else really has while
other individuals like the mindless ones
took on some sort of telepathic
abilities or took on enhanced mental
powers more so than they had ever
previously had that the orb is somehow
changing physically that his body is
physically reacting to this we see that
Nick theory begins to assault the orb
and begin to try to get information out
of him specifically how it was he was
able to access the secrets of the eye
how it was it he was able to access what
it is that the eyes had seen over the
course of the Watchers existence we see
that Nick Fury continues to tell the
order they don't have time to play games
that dr. - is still out there and he
wants to know again how it was that the
orb managed to open the eye what we see
here is that while Nick Fury is
interrogating the orb that one of the
life model decoys approaches him and
says that they'll be here soon
and if Nick Fury should be it should get
suited up what we also see going on here
is that Nick Fury takes the eye and puts
it into a container of sorts puts it
into some kind of a box and what he
tells us here is that while The Watcher
is dead while The Watcher never really
cared for him
while The Watcher didn't really like
Nick Fury in particular that there's no
reason why the Watchers secrets should
die with him and so what we basically
see Nick Fury doing here is what appears
to be putting the eye of the watcher in
some kind of a securing container from
here we see that one of the life model
decoys who is continuing to fight the
super heroes outside of this laboratory
door that Nick Fury has locked tells
Scott Lang that they have to understand
what Nick Fury was doing that the truth
is that Nick Fury was simply trying to
save the world from here we see that
this life model decoy has for the most
part been destroyed and that Doctor
Strange is trying to open the door to
the laboratory but the laboratory
appears to have some kind of magical
safeguards and Doctor Strange is curious
as to how it was Nick Fury was able to
do this how he was able to safeguard
against the magic that dr. strange
possesses what we also see is that while
these individuals are trying to break
into this room that dr. strange using
the third eye realizes that they may not
necessarily have to be the ones to break
in there that for the most part help is
on the way
and what we see is that the life model
decoys are reacting to the fact that
there's been a whole breach in Sector
nine and they begin to activate all of
the existing life model decoys on the
space station from here we see that a
full full organization or a full
grouping of the Avengers have arrived
and we see the Falcon Thor The
Incredible Hulk spider-man miss Marvel
Iron Man and various other individuals
as they begin to descend upon the
satellite and effectively do the best
they can to more or less destroy Nick
Fury or to the very least bring a stop
to his actions from here we see that
Captain America demands of one of the
life model decoys the location of Nick
Fury where the real Nick Fury is and to
tell him that the Avengers are here he
says that there's no more secrets that
there's not going to be any more lies
from here we see that there's some sort
of flash of bright light and some
individuals says no more secrets and
that they agree and then apparently so
does everybody else and what we see
going on here is that Nick Fury arrives
in his complete suit saying that his
eyes are all open and what we see is
that Nick Fury actually has both eyes of
The Watcher indicating to us that it was
in fact Nick Fury himself who had
actually been the one to kill the
watcher from here we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end and what
we're gonna find out an original sin
issue number seven and especially an
issue number eight is the full story
we're gonna find the full event of what
it is it's a case why it was that Nick
Fury had killed the watcher and what it
means for the Marvel community now that
The Watcher is dead so original sin
issue number seven is going to bring us
the second to the end of the original
sin series and what we're gonna get is a
lot of information in a very short
amount of time in this comic book and so
this story is gonna go very very fast
but what we're gonna see is this
transition between the past and the
present we're going to see a lot of
things taking place and we're gonna get
a lot of information especially when it
comes to who it was that had shot The
Watcher now we're not gonna find out who
it was that had killed the watcher what
the fatal injury was to the watcher were
so we just going to learn who it was
that shot him and we're gonna learn
there's a lot more to this story of
original sin then had initially been
brought to us and what we see as the
story progresses is that we're
transitioning into the past we're
transitioning into several days into the
past and what we see is that the orb
doctor - the daughter of doctor -
exterminate ryx and the mindless ones
have arrived on the moon now again if
you recall our discussion previously in
original sin we had talked about how the
mindless ones were exactly what they
sounded like there were extra
dimensional beings who remind us they
simply just existed to carry out the
will of whoever it is they could curry
their favor and at this point they
haven't been exposed to the eyes of the
Watchers so they haven't developed any
kind of abilities this simply just gives
us information as to how it was that the
initial explosion of the Watchers
Watchtower took place and what we see is
that the purpose of the orb and dr.
Midas and and these other individuals
being here is that they intend to rob
the watcher of his armament and his arms
now what this means in terms of what
they intend to do with the various guns
and armors they intend to obtain is
something we don't know
but I would go as far as to say that the
only real motivation here for dr. Midas
is to to expand his empire given the
alien technology that the watcher has on
the fact that there would really be
nobody on the planet who would be able
to oppose him just be
cuz of the power that he would possess
what we also see here is that the orb
says they've come here to be reborn
they've come here to go presumably
evolve or to take the next step in
possibly their evolution or become
something better than what they are
exterminate replies that she thought
they were just here to rob the watcher
and the orb says that - and what we see
is that as the orbit is forces
approached the entrance to the
watchtower the door doesn't immediately
open and dr. Midas thinks that the orb
has brought them here under false
pretenses and of course he gets a little
angry because of it but then we see the
door begins to open up from here we see
that the group immediately takes off
towards whatever they consider might be
the armory and they shout out to to tell
anybody if they find anything that seems
like an armory in addition we see
exterminate ryx saying that the watcher
watches everything that he sees
everything and so it's important that
they move quick because they won't have
before long before the watcher shows up
but then we see almost immediately after
they enter the Watchers watchtower that
the watcher appears through here we see
the Watchers say that he sees them and
dr. Midas says to go to plan B in which
case we see an explosion at the Watchers
watchtower from here we transition back
to the current day and what we see is
some sort of battle taking place on the
moon this presumably being the battle
between Nick Fury and the Avengers we
see that the Incredible Hulk has been
not towards the moon onto the surface of
the Moon and that Luke Cage appears to
either be incapacitated or possibly even
dead we also see the Captain America is
sending a priority alert saying that the
Avengers are requesting any sort of
spacefaring assistance because they're
in in combat on the earth in the Earth's
orbit they're in combat on the moon and
that the target is Nick Fury now with
Nick Fury fighting the Avengers one
thing to bear in mind here is that while
Nick Fury is able to single-handedly
combat all the Avengers and successfully
oppose and defeat them that he's able to
do this for several reasons the first is
because he possesses arms and armament
there are of alien design and so he's
able to combat the superheroes just on a
base physical scale but also what we
will see as the story progresses is that
Nick Fury is in possession of both eyes
of The Watcher
and because he has both eyes of the
watcher he knows all the secrets related
to the superheroes and he's going to use
these secrets against them from here we
transition to new Tony Stark attempting
to attack Nick Fury and Tony Stark of
course asked the question why it is at
Nick Fury so old and whether or not he
missed anything
make fury replies by saying that Tony
Stark has missed a lot of things over
the years that he couldn't possibly
imagine all the things that he's missed
all the things that he doesn't know
about but we see the Nick Fury says that
he doesn't miss in which he shoots Tony
Stark and doesn't necessarily
incapacitate his armor but is able to to
keep him off-guard for a moment or two
what we also see here is that the Falcon
and Wolverine attempt to oppose Nick
Fury and Nick Fury is able to for the
most part despite being detained
eventually throw them off he's able to
eliminate them from being able to keep
them keep him confined but we also see
him staying or see a Wolverine saying is
that Wolverine and the various
superheroes trusted him and maybe that's
where they went wrong that they put
their confidence in him despite the fact
that they didn't know exactly what it
was that he was doing at the time or
everything that had been going on what
we also see is a black widow trying to
rationalize with Nick Fury asking Nick
Fury to tell them what it is it's going
on to help them understand Nick Fury
says he wished that he could that he
wishes there was more time from here we
see that Captain America intervenes in
Captain America again attempts to
rationalize attempts to speak with Nick
Fury and get him to understand that he's
crossing this line he's crossing a line
that he can't come back from that
there's still time for him to turn back
there's still time for him to come back
from what it is that he's doing but that
if he does cross this line and he stays
across it that this window of
opportunity will close Nick Fury says
that he wish he could explain things to
Steve Rogers but that if he did explain
to Steve Rogers Steve Rogers would hate
him more so than anybody else Steve
Rogers replies by saying that he always
respected Nick Fury that again he
doesn't want Nick Fury to cross a line
that he can't come back from especially
after everything that they've been
through but Nick Fury says that he
crossed that line a long time ago and
that he believes he crossed the line for
right reasons and that's what we see
going on here we basically see this
conflict but
Nick Fury and the Avengers both of which
I believe that they're doing the right
thing that they have done the right
thing and with this much like Civil War
it's up for debate it's up for a
discussion as to whether or not who's
right here is Nick Fury right because he
believes that the end Zoro I'm sorry
that the means are appropriate if the
ends are satisfactory or is Captain
America right here and is saying that
there has to be some standard there has
to be some line the superhero simply
just don't cross what we also see is a
Captain America once he realizes that he
can't oppose Nick Fury directly due to
the fact that Nick Fury possesses armors
with enhanced physical strength causing
Thor and we see the Thor arrives to
again attempt to defeat Nick Fury on his
own Thor says that this will simply take
a few moments or so but what we see as
this progresses is that Nick Fury is
able to single-handedly hold his own
against Thor but again this is going to
touch on the element of Nick Fury
speaking with Thor and using the secrets
of various characters against them but
before that happens we transition back
to this to the satellite to the space
station and what we see is that Scott
Lang and the various other superheroes
that Nick Fury have been speaking with
before Hydra had retreated to his
laboratory are still attempting to open
the laboratory door and what we see is
that these superheroes are aware of the
conflict that's going on outside Scott
Lang says that they should be helping
him and are helping these various
individuals then we see that Emma Frost
says they should be trying to get out of
here that if they don't leave if the
other superheroes come back and find
them in here now the superheroes may
believe that they were fighting on
behalf of Nick Fury Moon Knight says
that they were that they were fighting
on behalf of Nick Fury and that is the
truth of the matter and that some
individuals may still be working for him
what we also see here is that when when
black black panther says this when black
panther says that some individuals may
still be working for Nick theory it
appears that he's speaking directly to
Bucky Barnes and Bucky Barnes takes
notice of this and says that he's the
one that cut off Nick Fury's head that
he's the one that brought Nick Fury's
head and revealed to everybody that Nick
Fury was a life model decoy and we also
see that Black Panther says that in
response to this that Bucky Barnes was
the one who was in possession of
the watchers I the watchers I that had
previously been held by the orb we also
see that Bucky Barnes responds to this
by saying that maybe black panther
missed the part where where Nick Fury
had shocked Bucky Barnes with his
walking stick and that Bucky Barnes had
been incapacitated at which point Nick
Fury took the eye but then we also see
the black panther responds by saying
that Bucky Barnes had blown up Moon
Knight ship and for the most part what
why Panther is trying to attempt to
establish here is that Bucky Barnes is
not really presenting any evidence to
indicate that he's not working for Nick
Fury did all his actions up to this
point make him appear very guilty the
fact that he had killed Nick Fury but
took his eye the fact that he was in
possession of the eye when Nick Fury
electrocuted him and the Nick Fury took
the eye which could very well have been
something that was set up between Nick
Fury and Bucky Barnes the fact that
Bucky Barnes had blown up Nick Fury or
blown up Moon Knight ship all this
evidence points to the fact that Nick
Fury may very well be working with Bucky
Barnes what we also see is black panther
I'm sorry Bucky Barnes accusing Black
Panthers saying that black panther is
the one who recruited all of them into
this investigation in the first place
and that's what's basically going on
here is that everybody is sort of
devolving into this kind of situation
where they're all accusing one another
well there's so much distrust here that
no one knows who's working for Nick Fury
or who's not or if anybody's even
working for Nick Fury they simply don't
know the answers to these questions and
because they don't know they're all very
accusatory they're all very confused but
they're all very unsure of what it is is
taking place from here we see that
Punisher Gamora and Rocket Raccoon
attempt to leave they say that they
simply just don't want to be here
anymore that there's some better place
to be than to listen to all of these
superheroes arguing amongst themselves
but then we see the doctor strange times
end and Doctor Strange says and nobody's
going anywhere that everybody here is
together in this so they're all part of
this situation and that they're all
going to decide together what their next
course of action is that regardless of
what Nick Fury's reasons were that they
think that Nick Fury or he argues the
Nick Fury is still a mass murderer and
that Nick Fury needs to be taken down
for this we also see that Doctor Strange
says that at the end of the day when the
history books come out
and people discussed this that they want
to be on the right side of history and
so he asks them who chooses this path
who it is that wants to be on the right
side so here we see that the orb shows
up and the orb asks if he gets a vote
here that because of the fact that the
watch or because Nick Fury took
possession of the eye because Nick Fury
had tortured him to gain information
about the eye that he votes at they kill
Nick Fury we then see that dr. strange
reacts to the fact that that the orb
appears to have a vast amount of power
here or the very least has somehow been
modified so that he looks similarly the
same but he has a sort of a purplish
aura about him and dr. strange asks what
it is a fury did to him Emma Frost
comments by saying she doesn't think
that it was Nick Fury but what we see
the orbs saying is that he stole all the
secrets that he stole all of the secrets
of presumably The Watcher including the
one that he's about to demonstrate at
which point we see him apparently use
some vast amount of power or some kind
of energy against the superheroes at
this point we transition back into the
past again and we see that when the the
villains the orb dr. Midas exterminate
ryx and the mindless ones had attempted
to combat the The Watcher in order to
rob him that the watcher appears to be
using the same kind of power against the
mindless ones and what this seems to be
is the watcher releasing secrets into
individuals and that appears to be the
power of the watcher to simply just
release secrets to people that as we had
established in the original sin issue
number zero when we learned about the
backstory of the watcher that despite
the fact that his race is very old and
very technologically advanced that
they're very humanoid that they can be
killed and so they're not these abstract
entities that we had previously been led
to believe that the watcher does have
power but if power simply seems to be to
just release secrets to people to inform
them of things that they were previously
unaware of or maybe to even wake up
Lincoln abilities that they previously
weren't aware that they had from here we
see the orb admiring the power that the
watcher has the orb is admiring what it
is the Watchers capable of and he talks
about what it would be like to have
power like that in addition we see
exterminates saying that they found the
armory and that they should grab
everything they can carry and then get
out of there what we also see is that
the orb is again completely admired by
what it is the Watchers doing and he's
almost hypnotized in this situation and
he asked the watcher if he's scared he
simply says you're scared on you and so
we see him take one of the guns from the
armory then he says the Watchers holding
back the Watchers holding back because
he saw but then he asked what it was
that the watcher saw what it was that
the watcher had seen when he had
presumably looked upon dr. Midas the orb
exterminate ryx and the mindless ones
when they had entered his base or
possibly even before and then he guesses
that the watcher had seen his death that
the watcher had seen that he was going
to die but that the orb had also seen it
himself and at this point the orb
expresses some kind of pity for the
watcher but it seems to be more of a of
a morbid kind of sadistic pity more so
than a genuine empathy related pity and
he says that he can make sure that the
watcher never sees anything again and so
we see that the orb shoots the watcher
from here we transition back to the
current time and what we see is that
during this conflict the Watchers eyes
has somehow left a possession of Nick
Fury and so spider-man uses his webbing
to capture the eyes and to keep them
from floating out into the depths of
space in addition we see that spider-man
comments on the fact that the eyes are
growing brightly that these eyes these
eyes are glowing in a way that he's not
really sure what to do with that he
doesn't know whether this is normal or
not from here we see that again the
comet is being made here about what
happened the last time that the eyes had
gone off that these secrets the secret
bomb so to speak had been detonated in
which voice which case
spider-man is talking about how all
these various secrets had been revealed
to all these superheroes and that all
sorts of crazy things were taking place
in addition we see Thor continuing his
fight against Nick Fury and that Thor
says it is time for Nick Fury to explain
himself his metal suit is not able to
withstand the might of Thor and his
hammer and so what we see is Nick Fury
replying by saying that that the Thor is
not going to be able to withstand the
power that Nick Fury possesses that
despite Thor's vast strength that Thor
also has secrets just like anybody else
and so we see the Nick Fury using the
eyes of the watcher touches back on
Thor and Loki storyline where he says a
Thor has a sister and he says one last
thing he also says that he sees
something else but before we find out
what that is we see that Thor accuses
him Thor says what it is he demands to
know what it is at Nick Fury is talking
about we demand to know he demands to
know how it is that Nick Fury was able
to access the Watchers secret and so
what we see is that Nick Fury mutters
something to Thor he whispers something
and what it is that he whispers to Thor
results in the fact that Thor loses the
ability to wield his hammer now what it
is that Nick Fury whispers to Thor is
something that we don't know at the
moment although I believe I have my
speculations one of which but again this
is simply just speculation here at this
point we see that Captain America is
standing on a satellite and he's asking
if anybody can see Thor we see that
Thor's hammer has fallen to the ground
along with an unconscious Incredible
Hulk again what we also see here is
Captain America asking Tony Stark if he
sees Thor if he's able to locate Thor I
can I'm sorry Tony Stark Iron Man says
that all you can see here is that Thor
is trying to lift his hammer on the moon
that he's trying to pick his hammer up
we then see that Captain America chimes
in and is a little confused here he asks
if what Tony Stark said is correct the
Thor is trying to pick up his hammer
from here we see that Nick Fury
approaches Iron Man from behind and
issues the override code for Iron Man's
suit to force him to return to Earth we
see the 20 stark doesn't know how it is
that that Nick Fury knew this but we see
that Tony Stark's suit immediately takes
off for the planet Earth removing Iron
Man from the conflict that's taking
place on the moon at this point we see
that Captain America doesn't really know
what's going on here he's asking Tony
where he's going but he's not getting
any response from Tony Stark's suit what
we also see here is that that spider-man
is simply just floating out into space
and again this lends credence to the
real place of spider-man in the Marvel
comics and while it's not necessarily a
popular opinion the fact that spider-man
is simply floating out into space and
can do nothing there's no one that can
help
him shy of anybody flying out to grab
him and bringing him back I think is a
testament to the fact that in a lot of
ways
spider-man is is part of a group that is
way above his league that for the most
part he can't really maintain with these
major spacefaring adventures from here
we transitioned back to Captain America
and Captain America again is speaking
with with Nick Fury and Captain America
here is trying to trying to rationalize
once again with Nick Fury but Nick Fury
at this point has laid waste to pretty
much all of the Avengers because at this
point we had the Incredible Hulk who is
unconscious on the moon we have Thor
who's no longer able to wield his hammer
Iron Man's suit has been sent back to
the planet Earth spider-man is floating
out into space and he tells Captain
America about how Wolverine had murdered
one of his own children about how
Natasha Romanov is more like Captain
America that she is like Nick Fury and
that for some reason or another this
secret or the secret he had revealed to
her had put her in a place to where
she's just simply no longer interested
in fighting anymore that she's no longer
capable of fighting and so between the
power that Nick Fury possesses given his
suit and his armament and the secrets
that he has revealed to various
superheroes all of the Avengers have in
effect been defeated and so what we see
is that Nick Fury says to - Captain
America that he's going to bring an end
to this conflict that years ago he had
watched a man die and that this man had
asked him when he's speaking about
Woodrow McCourt about whether or not all
of it was worth it that everything that
he had done was worth the result that
the ends had justified the means and
Nick Fury says that he didn't have to
previously and that he wish he had said
yes he wish he'd told him that yes it
was worth it that sometimes it takes the
worst of people to walk the worst of
roads in order for the best people to
follow and to do the things that can be
left behind to do the things to make the
rational decisions as to whether or not
this should still be maintained and so
what we see as Nick Fury saying his
goodbyes to Captain America he says he's
very glad that he met him and he says
goodbye from here we see that Nick Fury
turns a calm Stern's a communications of
his suit off and sets a course towards
the moon from here we see that dr. Midas
exterminate ryx and the mindless ones
have landed on the moon they have
reentered the conflict of the original
sense story and we see that what they're
going to do is in effect take everything
they're going to do everything they can
at this point we see that the Incredible
Hulk reawakens
but then the orb uses whatever power he
has at his possession presumably again
to use people's secrets against them to
incapacitate the Incredible Hulk once
more and again we see that Thor is
continuing to try to pick up his hammer
at this point we see the orb telling us
that this is the reason why he's here
that his dreams had led him to this
place that he was meant to be here and
that he's here to see the Watchers last
secret from here if we transitioned back
to a few days ago again and we see that
Nick Fury has arrived on the Watchers
watchtower
after the explosion that had taken place
in order to investigate what it is that
had gone on and what we see is that Nick
Fury is communicating with one of his
life model decoys saying that that he
thought it was a good idea or he knew it
was a good idea to have bugged the place
that he knew it was a good idea to to
set the devices in here to where he
could constantly monitor what it is that
was going on but the question that has
to be asked here is did The Watcher
allow this to happen because of The
Watcher sees everything The Watcher had
to have known that Nick Fury had entered
his base and planted bugs in order to
keep an eye on him and the watcher was
simply okay with this which begs the
question why was this okay with a
watcher or was assuming that Watchers
simply just wasn't concerned about from
here we see that as Nick Fury states
that he's going into the - the
watchtowers or the Watchers watchtower
that one of his life model decoys asked
the question of whether or not it's a
good idea that given his physical
condition the fact that he's not as
agile as he used to be and his past
history with the watcher as to whether
or not is something that he should do
but what we see is that Nick Fury tells
his life model decoy that or one of his
life model decoys that if he doesn't
come back then if he dies in the
watchtower to contact all the Avengers
and to inform them what it is that's
been going on all this
which basically means that he would have
his life model decoy communicate to them
that he is a life model decoy that all
these life model decoys exists they
haven't really dealt with the Nick Fury
for the real Nick Fury for quite some
time and the Nick Fury has been
travelling around the around various
dimensions the universe and the interior
of the planet Earth doing everything
that he had previously admitted to he
tells the life model decoys simply just
revealed to him to the Avengers the
unseen to tell them exactly everything
that's been going on and what we see is
that when he enters the watchtower he
realizes that there has been some kind
of a break-in he realizes that someone
has gone in here and stolen almost all
the arms and armament that the watcher
had but the watcher at this point is
still alive and he's saying that for the
most part that the watcher probably did
his best to fight these forces off
whether the watcher wasn't able to stop
him stop them on his own from here we
feel that the watcher takes note of Nick
Fury and Nick Fury is a little shocked -
shocked to see this the watcher or Nicky
are correctly guesses that the watcher
says that he didn't simply just do this
that that he didn't simply just do this
to mock Nick Fury that he didn't remove
one of his eyes to make fun of Nick Fury
he asked what it was that happened here
he asked Nick I asked the watcher what
is it this taken place to tell Nick Fury
what it was that he saw from here we see
that Nick Fury that we transitioned back
to Nick Fury as he's entering his base
and Nick Fury simply says that even back
then the watcher must have known what it
was that was going to happen the watcher
must have been aware of what it was it
was going to take place presumably the
fact that he was going to die and Nick
Fury says that at least this time that
at least when he enters the Watchers
base that there's not going to be
anybody watching but what we see what
Marvel reveals to us is that there are
multiple Watchers of watching this
entire conflict take place that all
these Watchers are monitoring Nick Fury
entering the Watchers base and that
presumably they've been monitoring the
conflict the entire time with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and what we'll see with
issue number 8 is the conclusion to
original sin and we will basically have
a multitude of questions answered but
with the way the original sin event will
end
we'll have more questions than the
questions that we had answered when the
entire original sin event took place
so as original sin comes to an end we
see the series conclude with issue
number 8 now the issue here with
original sin and one of the big
criticisms that a lot of us in the
Marvel community had is that original
sin raised just as many questions as it
answered and Marvel didn't really do a
good job of answering a lot of these
questions that cropped up what we're
also gonna do here in this discussion is
we're going to for the most part focus
on Nick Fury's involvement with regards
to The Watcher we're gonna focus on what
it was it took place and we're gonna
learn the truth about what happened with
Nick Fury and what happened with The
Watcher when Nick Fury arrived on the
moon and what we see here as the story
opens up is a transition into the past
into a few days prior to the current
events of the original sin event and we
see that Nick Fury has arrived after The
Watcher has been robbed and Nick Fury
asked The Watcher who it was that robbed
him that how this happened now he says
that the issue here is that the watcher
is in possession of a vast collection of
weaponry a vast collection of armament
that The Watcher sees everything and so
he knows most likely who it was that
robbed him and where they're going but
that if they take these weapons from the
Watchers armory if they take things like
the ultimate nullifier and various
weapons of badoon origin and they fall
into the wrong hands that it could lead
to total destruction of the planet earth
it could lead to a conflict on a scale
never seen before and so he says that
the watcher needs to explain what it is
that's going on The Watcher needs to
tell him what it was this happened what
we also see here is that Nick Fury says
that because the watcher sees everything
that it's the Watchers duty that despite
the fact that watcher doesn't
necessarily involve himself in various
events all the time that this is one
event whereby the watcher needs to take
some kind of action but the watcher
simply replies by saying that Nick Fury
is correct that the watcher does see all
things even the unseen and this is when
he reveals to Nick Fury the fact that he
can see everything or has seen
everything that Nick Fury has done
regarding his actions of fighting
various
multi-dimensional beams of killing
various multi-dimensional beings of
killing beings within the planet earth
and this upsets Nick Fury this angers
Nick Fury and the reason why is because
Nick Fury tells The Watcher that he's
always acted on the side of the planet
Earth that he's always fought to save
the planet Earth but that the watcher
always just watched that very rarely did
he ever actually step in and do anything
despite the fact that he had the power
to stop it that virtually any conflict
that could have arisen as a result of
these alien forces appearing had Nick
Fury not been there to stop him was
something that The Watcher could have
helped with The Watcher could have acted
in such a way to where it wasn't
necessary for Nick Fury to be the man on
the wall but instead the watcher never
did The Watcher simply just watched and
Nick Fury is angry about this and what
this does is this gives us this
dichotomy this inherent I guess
difference between Nick Fury and The
Watcher that Nick Fury's belief system
here is that it's not enough to simply
just watch it's not enough to simply
just observe there has to be somebody
that's going to actively oppose threats
and so Nick Fury views himself as the
true protector of the earth as the one
person who actually did anything to
ensure the earth was kept as safe as
possible and that the watcher despite
the fact that he never really did
anything had the power to do it but
never did always chose not to and so for
him The Watcher is a representation of
total apathy of an individual that has
the power to stop something but chooses
not to and so what we see is that Nick
Fury again begins to shout at the
watcher Nick Fury tells the watcher who
it is or ask the watcher who it is that
stole from him about what it is it
happened here then about who it is that
he has to kill next
from here we see that again the Nick
fear Nick Fury asked the watcher why it
is they took his eye why it is so they
took the important the eyes within his
head and he says that for the most part
he searched this place over and over
again that he has looked within this
place time and time again that even when
the watcher had passed out then he had
bugged the Watchers Watchtower in order
to keep an eye on him that the one thing
that he never noticed the one thing that
he never saw the watcher doing was
recording things physically the watcher
was never right
anything down the washer was simply just
observing all the time and so Nick Fury
deduces that most likely all the
knowledge and everything the watcher has
ever seen it has been stored within his
eyes that the reason why one of his eyes
was taken is because it possesses a
multitude of secrets now whether or not
that eye possesses all the same secrets
as the other eye is actually a question
that Marvel doesn't answer but for the
most part because both I saw the same
thing that seems to be the case and so
that would explain why both eyes weren't
taken from the watcher from here we see
Nick Fury pointing his gun at the
watcher and again telling the watcher to
answer him telling the watcher to tell
him what it is that he saw what it is or
who it was that came in and stole his
place I saw his stuff then The Watcher
simply just says that he's seen too much
that he's seen too many things and then
it's time for somebody else to watch
that it's time for somebody else to
undertake the role of the mantle of
watcher we see that The Watcher begins
to raise his hands against Nick Fury and
then he appears to be emanating some
kind of energy and that perhaps he may
be putting Nick Fury in a place where
he's going to force Nick Fury to shoot
him where he is in effect going to
commit suicide by cop but what we see as
the story continues is that we
transition back to the present day and
what we see is that the superheroes
Doctor Strange Hank Pym Emma Frost and
various other individuals have arrived
to aid Nick Fury in his fight against
the mindless ones and dr. Midas who of
course are laying siege to to the
Watchers watchtower and Nick Fury
respectively and what we see Doctor
Strange saying is that this is all going
to come to an end now that all of this
is going to end we also see that Nick
Fury says that he thinks they're here
because they've seen the truth in what
it is that he said and what it is it
needs to be done that there has to be
somebody to be the man on the wall that
he regrets the fact that he has to pass
this burden off to one of these
superheroes but somebody is going to
have to undertake this role but for him
it's a necessity it's something that
needs to be done so that the rest of the
superheroes can turn a blind eye so that
they can keep their hands clean but so
that they can also deal with whatever
let's left over whatever it is of the
man on the
is not able to stop but what we also see
dr. strange saying is that they haven't
come here to redeem Nick Fury they came
here because Nick Fury has one last cent
he has to confess - and Doctor Strange
demands to hear it Doctor Strange
demands to hear what it is that Nick
Fury did to The Watcher and Nick Fury
finally after the entire original sin
event admits it Nick Fury says that he
was the one who killed the watcher but
what we see is that for the most part it
appears that The Watcher had put Nick
Fury in a position where he had no
choice but to kill him that it was
either kill or be killed that the
watcher didn't really seem to have a
desire to live anymore now why it is the
watcher didn't really have a desire to
live is again something that Marvel
doesn't explain to us it's one of these
things that's left open but I would go
as far as far as to speculate that after
the events of original sin issue number
zero we had learned at The Watcher that
who watched The Watcher was looking for
any reality that existed where by his
father's actions didn't contribute to
the destruction of the the civilization
they had first encountered had never
existed that he was never able to find
this that he had for the most part just
kind of given up that he just didn't
really seem to have a reason to live
anymore and so we see that once Nick
Fury kills The Watcher that Nick Fury
takes his eye from here we pick up with
Bucky Barnes confronting Nick Fury and
Bucky Barnes tells Nick Fury to simply
put the eyeball down but Nick Fury says
that that it's not finished yet this
isn't done that dr. Midas is still
within the stronghold and that he's
gaining power and that somebody needs to
stop him and that Nick Fury thinks he's
the only one who can Nick Fury says that
this is his final act this is his final
way to save the earth his final action
in the role of the man on the wall and
he hopes that Bucky Barnes will one day
recognize what it is that he's done here
that Bucky Barnes will recognize the
necessity of what it is it has to be
done here and that maybe Bucky Barnes
will be the one to undertake the role of
the man on the wall from here we see
that Nick Fury enters the domain of the
Watchers watchtower and confronts dr.
Midas and doctor Midas appears to be
absorbing some sort of energy from the
watcher herb from the Watchers
watchtower seems to be emanating some
sort of force now how it is it he gains
this as something we don't really know
it just simply appears to be that he's
up
whenever cosmic energies have been
channeled through this place and so what
we see is that dr. Midas simply says
that if Nick Fury hands the eyes over to
him then he promises Nick Fury that he
won't have to watch what happens next
that he will not let Nick Fury see
whatever it is it has taken place now
whether this is some kind of taunt
saying that he's just going to kill Nick
Fury or what we don't really know but
before we get into what it is a doctor -
actually does we end up transitioning to
the orb and what we see is that the orb
is I guess being taken over by one of
the eyes of the watcher the Watchers eye
is merging itself with him but what we
also see here is that all these
different Watchers are watching this
event take place and the Watchers say
that it's their sacred vow that all they
can do is observe that they can't act
despite the fact that it's within their
power to do so but what we also see is
that all these other superheroes are
continuing to fight all these other
superheroes are continuing to take on
the mindless ones but for the most part
they really can't they really can't
understand what it is it's going on here
they really can't fathom what it is this
taking place here all this that's going
on with regards to dr. Midas using the
Watchers power Nick Fury's actions the
Watchers observing what's going on and
the orb
I guess being taken over by one of the
eyes of the watcher it's all way above
the head of a multitude of these
superheroes and so what we see Nick Fury
doing is that again as he transitions
into the past telling us that he had no
choice that it all had to be worth it
for him that he took the eyes of the
watcher took the eye of The Watcher
under the guise that he would be able to
find who it was that had killed the
watcher had a robbed the watcher in the
first place and continued to fulfill his
role of the man on the wall and that the
Watchers I would go towards him being
able to do his job in a way that he had
never experienced before that he would
be able to see almost all the forces
that were intending to attack the planet
Earth and that he wouldn't have to rely
on investigation or the normal means of
finding who these aliens were or the the
standard practice of whatever it was a
shield used for their intelligence
gathering and so what we see is that as
we continue with this story that dr.
Midas gets the eye of the watcher
plunged into his chest
as Nick Fury attempts to kill him and
for the most part it seems that the
power within the eye of the watcher is
able to totally override any power that
dr. Midas has and as the superheroes are
gathering outside of the Watchers
Watchtower they simply say that whoever
it is it comes out of this that whoever
it is it shows up after all this is said
and done that they take down hard that
they're going to ensure that whatever it
is that they're doing that in bed it's
stopped but we see that bucky bond says
that again kind of mirroring the
sentiment of Nick Fury that they can't
just stand here and watch we see Nick so
we see a Emma Frost comment that whether
or not Bucky Barnes is sure about that
and they look up to see that all these
different Watchers are watching this
event unfold from here we transition
back to dr. Midas and dr. - is again
being overtaken by the power of the
watcher and the Watchers eyes the power
simply just too much for dr. - is more
than his body can handle and so it
appears that his body is entirely
disintegrated that his body is totally
destroyed and so as the comic or as this
this begins to wind down as a comic
begins to come to a close we see that
Nick Fury is left next to the body of
the watcher and appears to have been
dying appears to in fact died from his
wounds suffered after the event of this
entire infinity storyline this entire
original sin storyline from here we
transitioned back to the super heroes
and the super heroes are simply gathered
around the the various parts of the
Watchers watchtower and what's the left
of it having after it had been destroyed
and Captain America simply says that
that The Watcher is dead that Nick Fury
is dead that all things all these
different things that have taken place
are going back to normal but one thing I
would like you to take particular note
of is this oversight that was made I
think by the artists of original sin
where Thor is continuing to hold his
hammer despite the fact that Thor has
previously been seen and will actually
be seen after this being unable to wield
his hammer and this I think was actually
something that was first spotted on
reddit but what we see Captain America
saying is that for the most part there's
really nothing left of Doctor Midas
there's really nothing left of Nick Fury
that after Nick Fury had died that his
full of the lmds had all just
disappeared that the mindless ones have
gone back to being mindless again but
for the most part everything has gone
back to the way it was before the
watcher had died before anybody had
manipulated his eyes and so for the most
part Captain America has no idea of what
it is is going on here he doesn't know
what drove Nick Fury to act this way and
he asked Doctor Strange and black
panther if they may know for the most
part what we see here is that Doctor
Strange asked Black Panther why it is
that he didn't tell Captain America what
it is that he knew and black panther
says he never tells anyone anything
and he asked Doctor Strange why he
didn't tell him and Doctor Strange says
that maybe he will one day that after
this is all said and done maybe he'll
tell Captain America about what's going
on but that after the eyes were used
against the superheroes after their
secrets were revealed to each other that
for the most part nobody trusts anybody
and that they've all become even more
secretive than they were before and that
maybe this secret whatever it is should
die with Nick Fury that Nick Fury is
presumably dead and that all these
things have finally come to a close but
what we see is that there's some
individual that's cloaked that is
wrapped in a cowl of some kind that's
simply just standing behind Doctor
Strange and black panther in a very
eerie sort of way and what we get is
this this bit of information or I guess
this sort of epilogue telling us what's
happened after very after the original
sin event had come to an end at this
point we transitioned back to some sort
of alien forces that are discussing the
fact that The Watcher has been killed
that various superhero groups are in
shambles and that now is the time for
these superheroes or for the planet
earth to be conquered and for their
forces to in vain but before they're
able to get too far one of his one of
them is shot in the face and we see that
Bucky Barnes the Winter Soldier has
undertaken the role of the man on the
wall and this as Marvel has explained it
to us is the precursor to the Bucky
Barnes Winter Soldier solo series where
we're going to follow Bucky Barnes as he
is part of the as he is the man on the
wall and is actually something that I'm
extremely excited about to see what it
is it happens and how his character
played
out from here we see that as Marvel
completely brings the original sin event
to an end as we get to the very end of
this comic that Marvel tells us that
things are winding down that things are
beginning to come to an end that all
these secrets that all these sins are
for the most part beginning to come to a
close and that there is an individual
there is a man that stands on the moon
and that his job is to forever watch for
eternity to watch but never interfere to
always be unseen and what we see is that
this man is Nick Fury that Nick Fury is
still alive but seems to be chained to
the to the moon seems to be chained and
stuck to the moon so that he can never
leave and so that for the rest of
eternity he will simply just monitor he
will simply just watch the planet Earth
and that he will never ever be able to
be allowed to interfere that he'll never
be able to undertake the role of being
the man on the wall with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and bring an event
or bring it bring it into the original
sin event I really hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]